Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 121.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Und ja, heute bin ich mal wieder unterwegs und der Weg
hat mich ins gute alte Darmstadt geführt, da wo alles hier schon mal begann.
Und das bedeutet, ich bin am ESOC, dem Europäischen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum,
da, wo die Satelliten gesteuert werden und andere verrückte Sachen passieren.
Und heute geht es um eine Mission mit dem schönen Namen EarthCare.
Das heißt, man kümmert sich jetzt mal ein bisschen um die Erde, wurde ja auch mal Zeit.
Und begrüße dafür heute gleich zwei Gesprächspartner, nämlich auf der einen
Seite den Björn Frommknecht. Hallo Björn.
Hallo.
Und den Thorsten, Thorsten Fehr. Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Genau, heute machen wir es mal im Doppel,
denn ihr seid beide bei EarthCare mit im Programm, habt aber so ein bisschen
unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen.
Du Björn bist Missionsleiter, also Chef vom Ganzen kann man sagen, oder? oder?
Könnte man so sagen, ja. Also meine Aufgabe ist es, dafür zu sorgen,
dass alle ihren Job gut machen können und dass wir das meiste aus der Mission rausholen können.
Und ich darf mich dann auch zum Beispiel um ein bisschen mehr administrative
Tätigkeiten kümmern, während die spannende Wissenschaft dann zum Beispiel vom Thorsten betreut wird.
Wie schön, genau. Und du bist Missionswissenschaftler, wie man so schön sagt.
Bestimmt auch nicht der Einzige.
In dem Fall bin ich der Einzige auf der ESA-Seite, wo wir noch später zukommen
werden. Es gibt natürlich auch noch unsere Partneragentur, wir machen es ja
nicht alleine, wir machen es in dem Fall zusammen mit unseren japanischen Kollegen.
Da gibt es auch noch einen Missionswissenschaftler, der dann auf der japanischen
Seite die Wissenschaft koordiniert.
Genau. Kommen wir doch vielleicht erstmal zu euch, fangen wir mal mit dir an, Björn.
Wann hast du denn angefangen das erste Mal in die Sterne zu schauen und warum Raumfahrt?
Ja, also ich habe eigentlich eine relativ bodenständige Ausbildung gemacht.
Ich bin Geodät, also Vermessung der Erde.
Ich habe in München studiert, an der TU München und bin da aber relativ schnell
in Kontakt mit Satelliten gekommen, weil wir Satelliten-Geodäsie gemacht haben.
Also die Vermessung der Erde mit Satelliten.
Habe da dann auch promoviert und bin dann in Kontakt mit der ESA gekommen über
die Schwerefeld-Mission Goce, Ghosts.
Und da haben wir angefangen. Unser Institut war quasi unter Vertrag von einer
italienischen Softwarefirma. So bin ich da reingerutscht, bin nach Italien gekommen, nach Esrin.
Und das hat mir dann so gut gefallen, dass ich dann da geblieben bin und habe
dann eigentlich auf allen wissenschaftlichen Erdbeobachtungsmissionen der ESA gearbeitet.
Das war GOCE, Cryosat, SWARM, EOLOS, ALTIOS und so weiter, bis ich dann jetzt
endlich bei EarthCare gelandet bin.
Ja, GOCE war hier auch schon mal ein Thema. Raumzeit Nummer 40,
da war ich 2012, ich glaube in München an der Universität, und habe mit Rainer
Rummel über das Projekt gesprochen.
Genau, das war mein Professor.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es da die Verbindung, ja?
Genau, die Kartoffel.
Genau, die berühmte Kartoffel des Geoid, genau.
Und wie war es denn bei dir, Thorsten?
Ich habe einen sehr ungradlinigen Weg zu ESA gefunden.
Das ist interessant.
Ja, ich habe erst Physik studiert, wollte unbedingt ans CERN gehen.
Das war immer mein Traum, Hochenergiefysik zu betreiben.
War auch am CERN und bin dann allerdings eher in die theoretische Physik gekommen,
wollte dann medizinische Physik machen, habe an einem Universitätsklinikum in
München gearbeitet und wollte dann promovieren in dem Bereich,
hat versucht mich zu bewerben und wollte mich als Test beim DLR bewerben.
Das war so gar nicht mal das Ziel, dass ich dort arbeiten wollte.
Und dann ist meine Bewerbung falsch gelaufen und die ist dann im Institut für
Physik der Atmosphäre gelandet. Die hatten eine Promotion für Gewitter,
für Wolken, für Stickoxide und das fand ich dann so spannend,
dass ich gesagt habe, das mache ich gerne.
Dann war ich erst am DLR, am Physik der Atmosphäre in Oberpaffenhofen,
habe dann dort primär Wolkenphysik gemacht, bis ich dann die Möglichkeit hatte
vom DLR zur ESA sekundiert zu werden.
Das heißt, die haben mich die Möglichkeit gegeben, dafür zwei Jahre hinzukommen
und bin dann auch in Estrin gelandet und habe dann primär auf Envisat gearbeitet.
Also Envisat ist, glaube ich, immer noch der größte Abbeobachtungssatellit,
den wir jemals gebaut haben, zumindest in Europa mit zehn verschiedenen Instrumenten.
Der VW-Bus in Space.
Der VW-Bus in Space. Ich glaube sogar deutlich größer als ein VW-Bus im Schluss.
Und habe dann da primär die atmosphärischen Instrumente behandelt.
Das war GOMOS, MIPAS und da war auch ein deutscher Beitrag bei Skiamaki dabei.
Und bin dann dort Qualitätsmanager gewesen, das sagt man so,
aber auch da schon die Wissenschaft mitbetrieben.
Und bin dann von Esrin nach Estik gewechselt, habe dann Kampagnen gemacht und
bin dann später als Missionswissenschaftler für EarthCare auch dazugekommen.
Esrin hat ja einen ziemlichen Schwerpunkt auf diesen Erdbeobachtungsmissionen, kann man sagen.
Das ist schon so ein Fokus.
Das Zentrum für die Missionsleitung der Erdbeobachtungsmissionen der ESA.
Das andere Zentrum wäre ESAC, das wäre dann für die Weltraummissionen.
Aber für die Erdbeobachtungsmissionen ist das Zentrum in Esrin.
Und genau deswegen sitzen die Missionmanager auch da.
Und dann zusätzlich natürlich in Estek, wo die ganzen Missionen auch gebaut werden.
Das heißt, wir sind wirklich europäisch aufgestellt. Wir haben das Erdbeobachtungszentrum
in Esrin in Italien, aber gebaut oder entwickelt werden die Missionen in den
Niederlanden, in ASTEC.
Das heißt, wir sind also wirklich ganz gut hier in Europa auch verteilt.
So, jetzt kommen wir zu EarthCare. Also wenn ich das richtig sehe,
ist EarthCare ein Projekt im Rahmen der sogenannten Earth Explorer Missions,
die wiederum zu diesem Living Planet Programm der ESA gehören.
Also es ist ja ohnehin so, dass die ESA sehr stark im Bereich Erdbeobachtung
ist generell und ich würde sagen auch führend eigentlich.
Also die, glaube ich, mit Abstand meisten Erdbeobachtungsmissionen sind letzten
Endes von der ESA initiiert.
NASA hat nach wie vor die Nase vorn, wenn es um Mars und einige andere Dinge geht,
aber das ist ja definitiv eine europäische Domäne und es sind auch schon so
viele verschiedene Missionen, dass ja dann man fast schon gar nicht mehr auseinanderhalten kann,
wer da jetzt eigentlich wo drauf schaut.
Daraus leitet sich ja im Prinzip dann auch gleich wieder die Frage ab,
also wozu brauchst du dann hier diese Mission?
Vielleicht können wir mal so ein bisschen in diese Vorgeschichte einsteigen.
Was war eigentlich jetzt erstmal der initiale Treiber, also die Uridee für diese Mission?
Was sollte sozusagen grob erstmal als Ziel erreicht werden und wie ist es dann gelaufen?
Du hattest ja schon vorhin erwähnt, dass wir, was die Erdbewerber angeht,
so mitführend sind auch global.
Und eine dieser Elemente, die wir haben, sind eben diese Earth Explorers.
Und die Earth Explorers sind ganz klar da, um wissenschaftliche Fragen zu beantworten.
Wir haben auch noch andere Elemente, das ist Copernicus, was wir zusammen mit
der Europäischen Kommission machen, ist für Services auch ein sehr erfolgreiches Projekt.
Wir haben noch die meteorologischen Systeme, die wir ganz spezifisch für die
Wettervorhersage zum Beispiel auch entwickeln.
Aber gerade die Earth Explorers sind dazu da, um wirklich wissenschaftliche
Fragen, sagen, fundamentale wissenschaftliche Fragen zu beantworten.
Und bei Earthcare hat sich schon in den 90er Jahren die Frage gestellt,
wie beeinflussen eigentlich Wolken und Aerosole, das sind diese kleinen Teilchen,
die in der Luft fliegen, das kann Dunst sein, das kann Staub sein,
das kann kleine Salzpartikel sein, wie beeinflussen die das Klima?
Das war so eine Fragestellung, die sich schon damals gestellt hatte.
Oder Vulkanasche.
Oder Vulkanasche zum Beispiel.
Genau. Ich hatte auch schon mal hier eine Sendung gemacht zur Atmosphäre,
wo natürlich die Aerosole auch eine große Rolle gespielt hat.
Damals mit Bernadette Weinzierl, die zu den Wissenschaftlerinnen gehörte,
die damals den unaussprechlichen isländischen Vulkan und die Auswirkungen davon untersucht haben.
Ah ja, Eyjafjallajökull.
War das jetzt auch richtig oder war das nur so getan? Ich glaube,
es war einigermaßen okay.
Bernadette ist jemand, mit der ich auch im Institut war.
Ah ja, okay, alles klar. Ja, genau.
Also Aerosole spielen eine große Rolle und Wolken spielen eine große Rolle,
das ist ja vollkommen klar.
Aber was weiß man denn dann noch nicht? Also ich meine, was ist sozusagen jetzt
der Trigger, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt brauchst du ja auch nochmal eine neue Mission?
Also wir alle kennen natürlich Wolken und Wolken ist das, was uns ja auch ständig umgibt.
Wenn wir an den Himmel schauen, meistens, so in meinem Fall in Holland,
da sehen wir ständig Wolken, meistens regnet es auch aus denen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip sind Wolken etwas, was wir eigentlich kennen und die Physik
der Wolken ist auch etwas, was wir kennen.
Schon über Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte auch schon uns genau anschauen.
Aber eine Sache, die nie ganz klar war, ist, wie beeinflussen Wolken auch das Klima?
Wir wissen ja zum Beispiel, dass Treibhausgase einen sehr deutlichen Einfluss
haben auf die Klimaentwicklung.
Wir kennen das sehr wohl, dass wir zum Beispiel unsere Klimagasemissionen auch
reduzieren müssen oder auf jeden Fall, um das Klima zu stabilisieren oder besser zu machen.
Aber der Einfluss von Wolken und Aerosolen auf das Klima ist etwas,
was nicht ganz so klar ist. Weil Wolken sind sehr schwierig zu greifen.
Wir wissen alle, Wolken sind schwierig zu greifen.
Wie die entstehen, wo sie entstehen und wie sie das Licht, was von der Sonne
kommt, reflektieren oder auch die Wärmestrahlung, die von der Erde abgestrahlt
wird, auch wieder zurückhalten.
Das sind so die Effekte. Und nachdem Wolken sehr komplex sind,
wir wissen das, wenn wir an einem Sommerabend den Himmel anschauen,
dann sieht man Wolken, die weit oben sind, Zirnenwolken, diese Wolken,
die wirklich nur ganz dünn zu sehen sind.
Man kann Gewitterwolken sehen, man kann Schönwetterwolken sehen.
Und all diese Wolken haben einen anderen Einfluss auf die Abstrahlung der Erde,
auf die Einstrahlung von der Sonne.
Und das ist, was die Sache so sehr komplex macht.
Also der ganze Zusammenhang zwischen Aerosolen, wie sie die Wolkenentstehung auch beeinflussen.
Und wie das dann auf den Strahlungshaushalt der Erde zurückfällt,
das sind die Punkte, die einfach immer noch sehr, muss man sagen,
nicht so genau zu wissen sind. Die sind noch nicht so sehr bekannt.
Und das ist auch in den Klimaberichten immer wieder zu sehen.
Bis vor einigen Jahren hieß es zum Beispiel, dass gaben diese Wolken-Aerosol-Klima-Auswirkungen,
die am wenigsten bekannten, am wenigsten gut eingeschätzten Bereiche unserer Klimaforschung sind.
Das hat sich in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen verändert, aber es ist immer
noch so, sodass wir hier einen großen Wissensnachholbedarf haben.
Und gab es denn nicht schon auch Missionen, Raumfahrtmissionen,
die sich der Wolkenthematik angenommen haben bisher?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, die meisten oder sehr viele zumindest von den meteorologischen
Systemen, die schauen sich natürlich auch Wolken an. Das ist ganz klar.
Das wollen wir auch machen. Aber was wir hier noch weitermachen wollen,
ist die ganz spezifische Wolkenentstehung auch sich anzuschauen.
Es gab schon Missionen davor. Unsere NASA-Kollegen hatten zwei Missionen.
Fliegen, die sehr ähnlich sind wie EarthCare.
Das eine ist der CloudSat, das war ein Wolkenradar, was geflogen worden ist,
sehr erfolgreich und auch ein LIDAR, da kommen wir auch später dazu,
wenn wir dann die Instrumente betrachten.
Das heißt, ähnliche Missionen wurden auch schon geflogen.
Aber diese Missionen waren zum Beispiel auf zwei verschiedenen Plattformen.
Das waren andere Systeme und mit EarthCare versuchen wir das nochmal deutlich besser zu machen.
Wir bauen natürlich auch auf diese Informationen auf, aber der Satellit,
den den wir haben, erweitert das Wissen noch deutlich.
Und wann ist jetzt das erste Mal darüber nachgedacht worden?
Also was ist sozusagen jetzt, wann ging es los?
Wann ging es los? Es ging los vermutlich in den frühen 90er Jahren,
wenn die ersten Ideen kommen.
Das heißt, den Zeitraum von der ersten Idee, wo ein paar Wissenschaftler,
so wie wir jetzt auch, am Tisch sitzen und sich unterhalten,
was wird benötigt, wo sind denn wirklich die Punkte, wo unser Wissen erweitert
werden muss, um die Welt besser zu verstehen,
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt jetzt, da kann schon mal ein paar Dekaden auch vergehen.
Also sprich, die Abfolge war, wie gesagt, Wissenschaftler unterhalten sich,
sie entwickeln ein Konzept,
Und dann können Sie mit dem Konzept natürlich auch zu ESA gehen.
Das ist praktisch der Werdegang.
Und hier ist es dann so gewesen, dass ungefähr 2001 das EarthCare-Konzept,
wie wir es jetzt sehen, wurde vorgeschlagen. Der ESA als ein EarthExplorer,
als eines der Missionen, die ganz spezifische wissenschaftliche Fragen auch beantworten.
2004 wurde es dann ausgewählt in die Implementierungsphase. Das heißt,
davor waren noch andere Missionen auch noch mit dabei.
EarthCare wurde ausgewählt, um dann weiter aufgebaut zu werden.
Ja und seit 2004 bauen wir die Mission auf.
Das heißt, es sind vermutlich jetzt dann 30 Jahre, dass von der ersten Idee
bis wo wir den Launch haben, hoffentlich jetzt dann bald Ende Mai,
aber so lange dauert das, bis es vom Konzept zum wirklichen ersten Datensatz auch kommen kann.
Mhm. Und die Kooperation mit JAXA, war die dann sozusagen von Anfang an da oder
hat man sich da später erst so entschlossen?
Also wie kommt das dann sozusagen, das waren jetzt so eine Mission auch konkret
mit einer anderen Agentur zusammen plant?
Das ist natürlich auch das Schöne an solchen Missionen, sowas wächst ja auch.
Das heißt, der erste Vorschlag, der gekommen ist von den Wissenschaftlern,
war die sogenannte Earth Radiation Mission, IRM.
Und diese Mission hatte noch keinen Lachseanteil dabei. Und natürlich sucht
man immer wieder auch nach Kooperationen, nicht nur die Wissenschaft.
Die Wissenschaftler arbeiten immer sehr, sehr eng miteinander.
Es ist wirklich ein globaler Austausch der Ideen.
Aber auch auf der Agenturseite war das Bestreben, hier eine Kooperation zu finden.
Und das kam dann so, dass die japanischen Kollegen Erfahrung hatten mit einem
Messsystem, was eben in Europa nicht so bestanden hat, mit dem Wolkenradar.
Und hier wurde dann praktisch vorgeschlagen, ja, die Japaner kamen,
wir haben dieses Wolkenradar, mit dem wir eure Mission noch besser aufbauen
können. Das war auch etwas, was notwendig ist.
Und dementsprechend haben dann die Japaner das Wolkenradar für unser System geliefert.
Das heißt, die Systeme, die wir auf Earthcare fliegen, sind vier Hauptinstrumente.
Drei davon sind europäisch.
Eins davon ist von den japanischen Kollegen.
Mhm.
Und gleichzeitig haben die Japaner auch dann um die Mission herum auch ihren
wissenschaftlichen Bereich mit aufgebaut.
Das heißt, wir haben also auch hier einen sehr regen Austausch zwischen den
europäischen und den japanischen Kollegen, wie es auch sein soll.
Das ist Wissenschaft. So muss es funktionieren.
Und dann ging es 2014 los.
2004 ging es los mit dem Bauen.
Mit dem Bauen, aber 2014 sollte eigentlich der Start sein. Darauf wollte ich hinaus.
Ja, ich glaube sogar 2013 hätte es zum ersten Mal der Start sein müssen.
Als ich zur ESA gekommen bin, war das glaube ich noch 2013.
Manche Dinge sind etwas komplizierter, als man am Anfang sich denkt.
Und deswegen hat es hier auch länger gedauert, bis wir es geschafft haben,
wirklich alle technischen Probleme zu lösen.
Manchmal dauert es länger.
Aber welcherlei Art waren jetzt sozusagen diese Probleme?
Also was genau war jetzt schwierig? War es ein Problem, die richtige Rakete
zu finden? Das ist ja oft, oder?
Also ich glaube, bei Earthcare haben wir eine schöne Sammlung an Problemen, die wir gelöst haben.
Also natürlich war es erstmal technisch einfach schwierig, die Instrumente zu bauen.
Also zum Beispiel das Instrument für die Aerosole ist ein UV-Laser, ein LiDAR-Instrument.
Und es ist einfach sehr schwierig, so ein Instrument weltraumtauglich zu machen.
Also das UV-Laser bedeutet, es ist hohe Energie.
Das heißt, wenn kleinere Verschmutzungen auf der Optik sind oder so,
dann verschmutzt sich das und ist nicht mehr benutzbar.
Also das stellt sehr hohe Anforderungen schon allein, um nur die Komponenten
zu bauen und dann zusammenzustellen, testen und so weiter.
Und das dann funktionsfähig über eine längere Zeit im Weltraum zu halten, ist nicht sehr einfach.
Und wir sind, wenn es dann hoffentlich funktioniert,
die ersten, die das über längere Zeit fliegen, wenn man absieht von der Eolus-Mission,
die ja Windmessungen mit einem UV-Laser, mit einem weltraumtauglichen UV-Laser gemacht hat.
Und das hat einfach immer wieder zu Verzögerungen geführt.
Je näher man dann kommt, um Teile des Instruments zu fertigen.
Zusammenzufügen, desto mehr Probleme kommen dann auch ans Licht,
die man dann in den Griff kriegt, aber halt leider unvermeidlich Verzögerungen in Kauf nehmen muss.
Was das japanische Instrument angeht, da gab es, wenn ich mich recht erinnere,
der Tsunami hat die Fabrik zerstört, in der Teile des Instruments gebaut werden.
Und dann muss man eben die Teile, also zuerst mal die Fabrik wieder aufbauen
sozusagen, die Produktionsanlagen und dann die Teile wieder bauen.
Ja, das hat natürlich, das war glaube ich mindestens ein Jahr Verzögerung,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Nur ein Jahr?
Also mindestens, es war vor meiner Zeit, da war ich noch nicht dabei.
Das ist mich ja sehr überrascht schon.
Aber ja, also das war so eine Serie an, sagen wir mal, Ereignissen und natürlich in letzter Zeit,
was für uns auch unerwartet war, der Ukraine-Krieg, der uns gezwungen hat,
den Launcher zu wechseln, zweimal.
War eigentlich eine Sojus. War eigentlich eine Sojus, soweit so gut,
alles dafür getestet und haben gedacht, das ist eingetütet, wenn wir mal so
weit sind, kann eigentlich nichts mehr passieren.
War dann aber nicht so und dann hieß es, okay, wir gehen auf Vega-C,
europäische Rakete, aber da war es einfach so, dass wir so am Limit waren von
der Spezifikation der Oberstufe.
Sowohl die Größe, wir hätten sozusagen Aussparungen in die Abdeckung machen
müssen, um den Satellit überhaupt reinzukriegen und auch, weil wir so schwer und so groß sind,
war das einfach nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt klappt und deswegen haben wir
ja dann Gott sei Dank die Erlaubnis bekommen, auf,
Falcon 9 zu wechseln, als,
Rakete, aber auch da ist es nicht so, man kann nicht einfach Rakete wechseln,
sondern es kommt ja immer wie die einzelnen Raketen verhalten sich unterschiedlich,
was die Geräusche angeht, Vibrationen und so weiter. Die Kräfte, die beim Start wirken.
Und das kann natürlich negative Auswirkungen auf die sehr empfindlichen Instrumente haben.
Und da muss man dann erstmal sicherstellen, dass alles den Start gut übersteht
und dann auch nach dem Start so funktioniert wie geplant. Also das war eben,
wir sagen immer, ÖSKR ist wirklich wie eine Achterbahn der Gefühle.
Immer wenn wir denken, wir haben es jetzt, dann kommt wieder was Neues.
Deswegen, wir sind bereit für alles.
Im Moment sieht es sehr gut aus. Der Start ist quasi morgen,
das ist in eineinhalb Monaten. Aber wir sind gespannt, was dann als nächstes kommt.
Genau, wir sprechen jetzt hier gerade im März 2024 und für den Mai besteht sozusagen
die Hoffnung, dass der Start stattfindet.
Stattfindet. Aber dieser Wechsel der Träger, das interessiert mich jetzt nochmal
gerade aus dieser Missionsleiter-Perspektive.
Ich meine, ihr werdet ja dann vorher sehr viel mit den Russen zusammengearbeitet
haben, die halt diese Sojus betreut haben.
Das ist ja auch, das ist ja jetzt nicht nur die Abarbeitung von so einer technischen,
Checkliste, sondern das sind ja auch Leute, mit denen man wahrscheinlich über
Jahre auch schon zusammengearbeitet hat.
Und ich meine, die Leute, die da in der russischen Raumfahrt arbeiten,
sind ja nun nicht unbedingt jetzt diejenigen, die daran Schuld tragen,
dass das dass alles jetzt ganz anders ist.
Jetzt muss man sozusagen von heute auf morgen letztlich auf ein amerikanisches Team wechseln.
Das ist ja dann auch kulturell, nehme ich an, schon ein Shift,
gerade weil jetzt auch SpaceX natürlich als rein privates Unternehmen wahrscheinlich
nochmal ein ganz anderes Grundverhalten an den Tag legt.
Wie war das so für euch? Ist das so, Raumfahrt, alle kennen sich,
Und das läuft schon und dann geht das von heute auf morgen oder muss man dann
auch Änderungen am eigenen Projekt in irgendeiner Form vornehmen,
ein neues Team aufstellen oder was hat das für Auswirkungen?
Also rein formell funktioniert das natürlich so, wir haben einen Hauptvertragspartner,
der auch dafür verantwortlich ist, den Satellit zu bauen und über den wir dann
auch den Start sozusagen machen.
Kaufen, wenn man das so w ill. Wer ist der Partner? Das ist Airbus Friedrichshafen.
Das hat sich nicht geändert, aber was sich da natürlich geändert hat,
ist klar, es gibt eine ganz andere Unternehmenskultur oder das,
was ziemlich schnell klar geworden ist bei SpaceX, das ist für die ein Staat,
das ist für die nichts Besonderes mehr und man ist einfach ein Kunde unter vielen.
Die haben so viel Geschäft, dass man, gibt es keinen Raum für Sonderwünsche
oder so, sondern man muss sich halt deren Rhythmus anpassen,
auch was zum Beispiel die Bekanntgabe von Startdaten und so weiter gibt.
Ihre Abläufe sind, sagen wir mal, inzwischen gut strukturiert und gut eingelaufen
und da machen die keine Ausnahmen normalerweise, nur weil wir sagen,
okay, wir sind jetzt die ESA und wir haben eine tolle Mission und sagen,
okay, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dann nehmen wir halt einen anderen. Also, wollt ihr, oder?
Das hieß natürlich auch, dass wir zum Beispiel bei den Preisverhandlungen für
den Start hat, da gab es nicht viel Spielraum, sondern es war halt ein bestimmter Preis.
Das war auch eine große Arbeit vom Projektteam, auch den finanziellen Aspekt
zu regeln, weil man natürlich für Soyuz zum Beispiel hat man schon einen Teil dann ja auch bezahlt.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man erst am Ende nach einem erfolgreichen Start zahlt,
sondern da fließen ja auch größere Summen schon, nicht alles Gott sei Dank,
aber das alles muss gehandelt werden Und dazu kommt dann eben auch noch,
dass es eben ein anderes Team ist, andere Abläufe.
Gut, man muss dann nicht zum Beispiel nach Kourou den Satellit transportieren,
sondern nach Amerika, Einfuhr, Zölle etc.
Also es gibt da einige Änderungen, die man nicht vorhersehen kann,
aber im Endeffekt haben wir es dann geschafft und es war ja auch nicht das erste
Mal, dass die ESA-Raketen mit SpaceX startet, sondern da gab es ja schon Vorläufer
und da haben wir uns natürlich dann auch abgesprochen mit den Kollegen.
Es macht natürlich auch programmatisch einen großen Unterschied.
Ich meine, natürlich als europäische Raumfahrtagentur ist unser Ziel natürlich
auch mit einer europäischen Rakete unsere Satelliten in den Orbit oder in den Saal zu bringen.
Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, wo wir umdenken mussten, dass wir sagen,
okay, können wir rausgehen?
Wer kann denn das anbieten? Und hier muss man sagen, da haben auch im speziellen
Fall von Earthcare uns die Mitgliedstaaten auch durchaus unterstützt.
Also es war natürlich klar, am Anfang wollten die auf ihre Seite,
dass wir nach Sturios auf Vega-C gehen, einfach um sicherzustellen,
dass auch hier europäische Systeme verwendet werden.
Aber aufgrund auch der Notwendigkeit der Messung.
Deswegen konnten wir dann auch unsere Mitgliedstaaten davon überzeugen,
dass wir eben auf einen kommerziellen, auf einen amerikanischen Launcher auch gehen.
Und es ist auch wichtig zu sehen, dass wir hier die Flexibilität auch haben.
Wenn Sachen notwendigerweise gemacht werden müssen, wenn was passieren muss,
dann finden wir auch einen Weg.
Also es ist nicht, dass wir hier ganz verbotprogrammatisch sagen,
es muss aber so sein, sondern wenn wir müssen, dann können wir auch anders denken.
Ja, Euclid, das Weltraumteleskop, das vor kurzem gestartet ist,
hat ja im Prinzip dieselbe Geschichte gehabt.
Auch da sollte es ja mit einer Sojus hochgehen und ist dann am Ende mit SpaceX
erfolgreich gelauncht worden.
Das steht euch dann sicherlich auch bevor. Ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich.
Jetzt sind wir ja noch vor dem Start, aber mich würde trotzdem kurz interessieren,
was ist jetzt die konkrete Raumfahrtmission?
Also wohin geht die Reise mit dem Satelliten?
In was für einen Orbit soll er denn nun kommen und warum und wie kommt er da hin?
Okay, also die Bahn ist polare Bahn.
Das heißt, man fliegt vom Nordpol zum Südpol oder vom Südpol zum Nordpol, je nachdem wie rum.
…ist nur ein ein Katzensprung…
Weil sich dann einfach die Erde drunter wegdreht. Also typisch für Erdbeobachtungsmissionen,
damit man polare Orbits hat. Im Prinzip eine komplette Abdeckung der Erde, beobachtungsmäßig.
Bahnhöhe sind 400 Kilometer, relativ niedrig.
Und es heißt Sonnensynchron. Das bedeutet, dass die Bahnebene sich einmal im
Jahr um sich selber dreht, damit immer Sonne auf die Solarpanels scheint,
weil wir einen sehr hohen Energiebedarf haben. Wir haben aktive Instrumente.
Also immer scheint sozusagen.
So viel wie möglich. Man muss ja korrekt sein. Es macht bei den Jahreszeiten einen Unterschied.
Es gibt dann auch Phasen, wo wir quasi Eklipsen haben.
Also wenn wir durch den Schatten fliegen, wo wir ein bisschen weniger haben,
aber immer noch so, dass die Batterien voll bleiben praktisch und dass wir keinen Energiemangel haben.
Wir brauchen ungefähr 1,7 Kilowatt an elektrischer Energie. Das ist relativ viel Energie.
Für so einen normalen Erdbeobachtungstatelliten ist das schon,
also unser Solarpanel ist, wenn ich es richtig, jetzt hoffe ich,
ich erinnere mich richtig, ist glaube ich elf Meter lang.
Elf und ein halb Meter.
Und das ist schon größer als, jetzt sagen wir mal, bei den normalen.
Was wäre so ein typischer Strombedarf?
Ja, unter einem Kilowatt vielleicht, um Größenordnungsmäßig.
Aber wir haben eben zwei aktive Instrumente und dann verdoppelt sich das fast.
Okay. Okay.
Und am energiehungrigsten sozusagen ist der LIDAR, der Laser.
Aber auch das Radarinstrument hat fast gleich so viel.
Das heißt, der LIDAR wird dann nach Norden oder nach Süden gestartet?
Der wird dann, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, nach Süden gestartet.
Also wir starten von Kalifornien aus und fliegen dann Richtung Antarktis.
Also wir fliegen sozusagen, wenn man es so einfach sehen will,
von oben nach unten, von Norden nach Süden runter.
Und Sonnensynchron heißt auch, dass wir dann immer zur selben lokalen Zeit am
selben Ort sozusagen vorbeifliegen.
Ich glaube, wir haben 14 Uhr.
Ja, und 14 Uhr ist auch wichtig, weil wir wollen ja uns Wolken anschauen.
Und wir wissen, dass es auch bei der Entstehung von Wolken über den Tagesgang
hinweg auch immer Zeitpunkte gibt, wo es mehr oder weniger Wolken gibt.
Das heißt zum Beispiel morgens haben wir relativ wenige Wolken.
Das heißt zum Beispiel auch viele Satelliten, die keine Wolken haben wollen,
die praktisch nur mit der Kamera die Erde beobachten, die wollen eigentlich
lieber morgen fliegen, Irgendwann hat es weniger Wolken.
Wir sind genau im umgekehrten Fall. Wir wollen eigentlich Wolken haben.
Das heißt, wir haben für unseren Satelliten 14 Uhr ausgesucht als die lokale
Zeit, in der wir praktisch über die Erde messen.
Also 14 Uhr, also immer da, wo man ist, ist es gerade 14 Uhr?
Das muss man sich so vorstellen, ja.
Also ich meine, so mit Uhrzeit und wenn man über die ganze Welt fliegt, ist ja so eine Sache.
Wir können sagen, dass praktisch, wenn immer wir den Äquator bei Tageslicht
überqueren, ist es 14 Uhr. Und die Erde dreht sich praktisch unten durch.
Das ist der Zeitpunkt der Äquatorüberquerung. Da ist es am Äquator.
Am Äquator ist es 14 Uhr.
In der jeweiligen Zeitzone oder hier?
Lokal. Es ist immer in der lokalen Zeit. Ansonsten, die Wolken halten sich ja
nicht an die globale Zeit.
Und 14 Uhr ist sozusagen so der optimale Wolkenzeitpunkt?
Das ist ein sehr optimaler Wolkenzeitpunkt.
Warum ist das ein optimaler Wolkenzeitpunkt?
Das ist praktisch, bevor auf der Landmasse die Konvektion einsetzt.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns Europa anschauen, das ist ja bloß ein kleiner Teil der
Welt. Die Tropen sind natürlich der größte Teil der Welt.
Und hier ist es so, dass die Konvektion am frühen Nachmittag einsetzt.
Wir wollen praktisch dieses Einsetzen auch der Konvektion, auch diese Wolken
mitnehmen. Auf der anderen Seite...
Mit Konvektion meinst du?
Oh, Konvektion, Entschuldigung. Konvektion bedeutet, wie sich die Wolken entstehen.
Wir kennen das ja alle auch bei uns an einem schönen Sommertag.
Wenn wir mal einen richtigen Sommer haben, dann entstehen immer am Nachmittag
die Gewitter. Das ist der ideale Sommerfall.
Am Nachmittag entstehen Gewitter und das ist das Entstehen von diesen Wolken.
Es muss nicht mal gleich Gewitter sein.
Das nennen wir Konvektion. Das heißt, die Luft steigt vom Boden in die Höhe
und bildet dabei Wolken aus. Und das passiert in den Tropen eben ungefähr um diese Uhrzeit auch.
Umgekehrt, die Wolken über dem Meer bilden sich meistens am Vormittag.
Das heißt, wir nehmen das auch noch mit. Das heißt, diese 14 Uhr sind im Prinzip
der optimale Zeitpunkt, um vom Satelliten aus Wolkenfelder zu betrachten.
Du schaust noch ein bisschen kritisch.
Aber Ich versuche es mir nur gerade so vorzustellen, wie man so auf diese Optimierung
kommt, aber es ist ja nachvollziehbar Also man will natürlich irgendwie nicht
genau dann irgendwo langfliegen, wenn da keine Wolken sind Genau.
Wir wollen ja Wolken vermessen und deswegen müssen wir uns das so ein bisschen
optimieren, wo finden wir den Zeitpunkt an dem die Wolken da sind nicht zu viele,
nicht zu wenige, damit wir das auch alles schön bestimmen können.
Weil es halt hier in dieser Mission auch konkret um das Untersuchen der Wolken geht.
Es geht jetzt hier nicht so sehr um festzustellen, ob da Wolken sind oder nicht,
sondern man will eigentlich so viel Wolken sehen, wie es nur irgendwie geht,
weil man sie sich genau anschauen möchte.
Weil bei anderen Erdbeobachtungen will man halt alle Wolkenfelder sehen oder
Wettersatelliten wollen natürlich sozusagen auch sehen, wenn da keine Wolken sind.
Also das ist glaube ich schon etwas, was man auch im Kopf haben muss,
wenn es jetzt hier sozusagen um das ganze Design geht.
So gesteuert wird das dann alles von Von Darmstadt aus?
Genau, also die Flugkontrolle ist in Darmstadt. Das heißt, der Satellit wird
hier von dem Kontrollzentrum in Darmstadt ausgeflogen, kann man sich so vorstellen.
Die Kommunikation mit dem Satelliten findet dann über Bodenstationen statt,
die auf der Erde verteilt sind. sind.
Vorzugsweise nimmt man welche, die an den Polen sind, wenn man kann,
weil die einfach dann jeden Vorbeiflug auch sehen.
Weil wir fliegen jedes Mal, bei jedem Umlauf fliegen wir über die Pole und das
heißt, da kommen wir dann vorbei und da kann man dann sowohl Daten runterladen,
also die wissenschaftlichen Daten.
Also Pole heißt jetzt nicht am Nordpol, sondern halt möglichst weit nördlich, so Kiruna oder so.
Svalbard zum Beispiel, was ja schon relativ weit nördlich ist,
auf jeden Fall nördlich vom Polarkreis, wenn man kann.
Genau am Nordpol Pol nicht, das ist richtig, da gibt es keine Station.
Aber es gibt eben, auch in Kanada zum Beispiel, je näher am Pol,
desto besser für die Station.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Geschäft, das sich ausweitet.
Und am Pol kann man ja nicht so, ist das Feuerland?
Trollstation.
Auf der Antarktis?
In der Antarktis ist es natürlich schwieriger zu erreichen, logistisch und so weiter.
Datenverbindungen, da muss man dicke Kabel legen. Und das ist schwieriger in der Antarktis.
Heißt die Station Troll?
Troll, ja.
So wie der Troll, ja?
Wie der Troll, ja. Ich glaube, es gibt keine Trolle. Ich war noch nicht dort, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber Pinguine wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Okay, das heißt, da werden dann halt die Daten eingesammelt und ich vermute
mal, da kommen auch eine ganze Menge Daten runter.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also wir liegen ungefähr, um eine Größenordnung zu geben,
ungefähr bei 60 Gigabyte pro Tag alles zusammen.
60 Gigabyte pro Tag?
Ungefähr, ja.
Okay, und wie viel Ausfall kann man sich dann erlauben, sollte es mal Probleme
mit der Datenstation geben?
Also unser Ziel bei unseren Wissenschaftsmissionen ist, dass wir eigentlich
keinen Ausfall haben wollen. Wir wollen das wirklich maximieren.
Aber ich meine, wäre jetzt sozusagen eine Bodenstation mal für eine Weile nicht
in der Lage, die Daten anzunehmen, wie viel kann der Satellit zwischenspeichern?
Ah okay, da sind wir glaube ich bei fast zwei Tagen, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Also da ist eine gewisse Toleranz und wir haben zwei Bodenstationen für die
Daten allein, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir da was überschreiben,
ist eigentlich relativ gering.
Und die 60 Gigabyte sind dann sozusagen jetzt also brutto, was man am Ende rausbekommt?
Die Rohdaten sind weniger, das sind alle Produkte zusammen, also quasi alle
Verarbeitungsstufen zusammengerechnet, japanische Produkte, europäische Produkte,
also wirklich komplett global.
Aber ist das jetzt sozusagen der reine komprimierte Datenstrom oder ist das
das, was man am Ende erhält?
Der komprimierte Datenstrom sind vielleicht ungefähr 10 Gigabyte.
Das ist deutlich weniger.
Ja, klar. Gut, das heißt, aber auch 10 Gigabyte muss man natürlich erstmal wegkriegen.
Ich meine, wie lange dauert so ein Polarer Orbit letztlich?
Ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden. So ein Überflug über eine Bodenstation dauert ein
paar Minuten, fünf, sechs Minuten, zehn Minuten maximal, kommt drauf an.
Die Länge variiert ein bisschen, aber das reicht locker aus,
um die Daten runterzuladen. und dann werden sie im Prinzip in das Datenverarbeitungszentrum
übermittelt und dann prozessiert.
Wir haben ja einen Nutzerkreis, dem es wichtig ist, die Daten so schnell wie
möglich zu bekommen und das ist die Wettervorhersage.
Wir haben ja mit ECMWF, dem Zentrum, eine Zusammenarbeit, wo wir dann die Daten
von den aktiven Instrumenten so schnell wie möglich geben wollen,
um dann die Wettervorhersage zu verbessern.
Was ist das für eine Organisation? EWF?
European Center for Medium Weather Forecast, ECMF.
Gibt es auch auf Deutsch. Europäisches Zentrum für Mittelfristvorhersage.
Ich bin schon zu lange... Genau.
Ja, okay.
Das heißt, es ist eben nicht so, dass man jetzt nur Wissenschaft in dem Sinne
macht, sondern die Daten, die in dem Moment auch akut sinnvoll sind für die
Wetterbeobachtung, werden auch noch mit ausgeschieden.
Das ist richtig. Also da haben wir sozusagen eine operationelle Anwendung,
so könnte man das bezeichnen, was über unsere ursprünglichen Missionsziele hinausgeht.
Der schöne Nebeneffekt dabei ist, dass in dem Moment, wo die Kollegen das in
ihre Wettermodelle einspeisen, sehen die sofort, wenn da was nicht stimmt.
Wenn die Daten, sagen wir mal, irgendwelche Abweichungen haben,
sich anders sind als sonst, dann würden die das sofort sehen und können uns
das als Rückmeldung geben, was natürlich für uns super ist. Das ist sozusagen
wie ein Frühwarnsystem.
Bevor wir die Daten großartig verarbeitet haben, würden die schon sehen,
okay, da können es Probleme geben. Müsst ihr genauer reinschauen.
Was könnte da schief gehen?
Es kann alles mögliche schief gehen. Es kann in der Prozessierung schief gehen.
Aber ich möchte nochmal kurz auf das ICNRBF, auf das Europäische Zentrum für
Mittelfristfähigkeit zurückkommen.
Die benutzen unheimlich viele Daten. Die können bodengespülten sein,
die klassische Wetterstation.
Das kann von Flugzeugen kommen, das kann aber auch von Satelliten kommen.
Das heißt, die haben unheimlich viele Daten, die sie in ihren Vorhersagen verarbeiten.
Wir nennen das assimilieren. Die nehmen die Daten und versuchen dann damit ihre
Vorhersagen zu verbessern.
Und wenn jetzt ein Satellit oder ein Datenstrom, wie zum Beispiel EarthCare,
nicht in das Schema passt, dann bekommen die sozusagen eine Warnung und sagen,
schaut, bei euch funktioniert was vielleicht nicht richtig.
Das kann auch sein, dass wir die Einzigen sind, die diese Daten zur Verfügung
stellen und deswegen sind die besonders.
Aber sehr häufig kann man auch sagen,
okay, die machen so eine Art Qualitätsmonitoring, die checken das ab.
Und das ist für uns natürlich extrem interessant, dass wir praktisch direkt,
near real time nennen wir das, so praktisch fast zeitnah, auch diese Art der
Qualitätskontrolle bekommen.
Die vergleichen wirklich alle möglichen Datensätze untereinander,
EarthCare ist eins davon und können dann direkt sagen, wo wir stehen.
Und wie schnell landen die Daten dann dort? In Reading ist das.
Wettervorhersage funktioniert so, im Moment machen sie vier Prozessierungsläufe
am Tag. Das sind sechs Stunden Zeitfenster.
Und die Daten, wenn ich in einen Prozessierungslauf reinkommen will,
dann dürfen meine Daten relativ zum Startpunkt nicht älter als sechs Stunden sein.
Also hier dreht es sich wirklich um Stunden. Deswegen versuchen wir auch,
auch eben jeden Überflug über den Pol, auch die Daten runterzuladen.
Ist natürlich ein Kostenfaktor. Jeder Pass, wie man das nennt, hat seinen Preis.
Aber wir versuchen wirklich, den Anteil der Daten, die wir mit dieser geringen
Verzögerung liefern können, zu maximieren.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip auch so ein Notfallsystem.
Wie müsste man sich das so vorstellen?
Sagen wir mal, ein Sensor dreht jetzt mal komplett frei. Und auf eine Art und
Weise, wie man das jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres jetzt erstmal aus den Daten herauslesen kann,
sondern ihr bekommt das eigentlich nur indirekt über die Meldung,
also über die Übertragung der Daten zu dem ECMWF,
langer Begriff, sozusagen mit. Also die stellen das dann fest.
Wie lange dauert das, bis die...
Und daraus sozusagen auch eine akute Warnung erzeugen. Und wie laut ist die
Sirene, die dann hier losgeht?
Also es kommt darauf an. Wenn es Fehler sind, die, sagen wir,
unmittelbar die Daten drastisch verändern,
dann sehen wir das nicht nur da, das sehen wir nicht nur am Europäischen Zentrum
für Mittelfristvorhersage, sondern wir haben auch unsere eigenen,
sagen wir, Qualitätskontrollen.
Also wenn jetzt einfach sowas kaputt ist, dann merkt man sofort.
Aber wenn das so eine Degradation ist über die Zahlen.
Genau, das sind die Punkte, die natürlich für uns sehr viel interessanter sind.
Wenn was auf einen Schlag nicht mehr funktioniert, das sehen wir auch.
Dazu brauchen wir kein ISMWF, dazu brauchen wir auch keine großartige,
sagen wir mal, Analyse-Technik.
Sondern hier geht es darum, wenn man sagt, okay, da ist so ein leichtes Drift drin,
keine Ahnung, eine Temperaturveränderung auf dem Spiegel von dem LIDAR-Gerät
oder irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten, wo man dann sagt, okay, über einen gewissen
Zeitrahmen, ihr fallt immer mehr raus.
Und das ist das, was für uns eigentlich dann wirklich interessant ist.
Und dann können wir auf unserer Seite anfangen zu überlegen,
woran hängt es? Ist es eine Prozessierungssache? Ist es was vom Instrument?
Und können dann auch entsprechend korrektive Maßnahmen auch starten.
Und das ist wirklich hier eher diese mittelfristige Monitoring,
diese Qualitätskontrolle, wo wir stark daran interessiert sind bei denen auch.
Na genau, also wenn man sozusagen will, die Gesundheit des Satelliten und der
Instrumente, die wird von der Flugkontrolle auch überwacht und ebenso,
sagen wir mal, grobe Aussetzer oder wirklich,
wenn was kaputt gehen würde, das würden die auch sofort sehen, einfach an der,
das nennt man dann die Housekeeping Telemetry, also die Gesundheitsdaten von
dem Satellit, wenn man hier wirklich auf eine längerfristige Qualitätskontrolle
und Sicherung abzielt dann.
Also es ist quasi eine Ebene drunter.
Aber wenn ich nochmal ganz kurz auf die Wettervorhersage und EarthGal zurückkommen kann.
Als die ersten Ideen kamen, das als Wettervorhersage, also für die Wettervorhersage
auch zu verwenden, da habe ich meinen Kollegen gesagt, das funktioniert nie.
Weil ich komme aus dem Bereich und das war 2007 ungefähr.
Da hat ein sehr guter Kollege von mir, der leider verschrauben ist,
aber diese Sachen angefangen hatte, der kam mit den ersten Ideen und ich habe
gesagt, das kannst du vergessen, das funktioniert nie. kann nicht funktionieren.
Ich komme aus dem Bereich.
Und hier einfach, du musst dir überlegen, du versuchst in ein numerisches Modell
was reinzupressen, was vielleicht gar nicht dahin kommt.
Du hast eine Vorhersage und was die machen ist, die lassen es erstmal laufen
und dann versuchen sie es zu verändern.
Das heißt, sie versuchen es so hinzudrehen, dass es so ein bisschen wie die Messung auch aussieht.
Und wenn du Temperatur oder Wasserdampf hast, dann ist es eine relativ einfache Sache.
Das ist groß verteilt, das ist nicht wirklich sehr sehr lokal,
aber wenn du versuchst eine Wolke irgendwo in ein numerisches Modell,
in ein Wettervorhersagemodell reinzutun, wo sie gar nicht ist,
wird es natürlich sehr schwierig, weil du kannst ja nicht irgendwie hier plötzlich
ganz viel Wasser entstehen lassen. Das lassen numerische Modelle nicht zu.
Und dennoch haben die Kollegen vom Europäischen Zentrum für Mittelfristvorhersage,
Entschuldigung, dass das so ein langer Name ist, die haben das dann über diese
Jahre geschafft, die Modelle so auch zu verändern,
dass sie hier jetzt auch auch EarthCare-Daten auch mit einlesen können.
Also das ist, weil wir hatten schon die Frage gehabt, was sind denn die Dinge,
die wirklich einfach nicht vorhersehbar waren und die Dinge,
die entwickelt worden sind,
ohne dass wir eigentlich jemals daran bei der Missionsdefinition so konkret
daran gedacht haben, das ist einer von den Dingen.
Das ist wirklich dieses Assimilieren dieser Wolkendaten, insbesondere in ein
Wetter-Frächer-Sage-Modell, ist
etwas, was wirklich auch mit EarthCare angefangen hat, auch ganz Neues.
Und das ist wirklich auch, wo man sagen kann, die Wissenschaft hat hier einen
großen Schritt mit uns schon vor dem Launch auch schon gemacht.
Bevor wir vielleicht auch konkreter mal auf die Instrumente zu sprechen kommen,
nochmal so, die Inbetriebnahme eines Satelliten ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Man fliegt ja nie los und kaum, dass das Ding das erste Mal über die Pole ist,
schaltet man die Datenpumpe an, sondern man muss man ja erstmal sicherstellen,
dass das auch alles irgendwie funktioniert und dass das eben auch belastbare Daten liefert.
Zumal wenn man das erste Mal solche
Daten erhebt, hat man ja in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keinen Vergleich.
Wie ist das jetzt hier geregelt? Also wie funktioniert da diese Inbetriebnahme
und diese Validierungsphase?
Wie parametrisiert man das sozusagen? Also wie ist man sich sicher,
dass es auch funktioniert?
Ich fange mal an mit dem Anschalten. Also das ist natürlich alles streng festgelegt,
in welcher Reihenfolge man welche Teile des Satelliten aktiviert.
Der erste Schritt ist immer Energieversorgung sicherstellen,
das heißt das Solarpanel ausfahren. Dann fahren wir die Antenne vom japanischen
Instrument, von dem Radar aus.
Und dann werden sukzessive die Instrumente angeschaltet. In unserem Fall ist
es so, dass wir erst das Radiometer anschalten und das Radarinstrument,
weil die keine Optik haben.
Das heißt, die müssen nicht, wie man sagt, ausgasen erst mal,
damit man sicherstellt, dass da keine Verunreinigungen sind,
die sich einbrennen würden, wenn wir die anschalten.
Das heißt, es gibt auch einen klaren zeitlichen Ablauf. Also am Anfang haben
wir Daten vom Radar und vom Radiometer und dann ungefähr nach sechs Wochen schaltet
man dann die optischen Instrumente ein und bekommt da dann die ersten Daten.
Und zeitgleich mit unserem Start findet auch eine sehr große Validationskampagne
statt und da kann der Thorsten wahrscheinlich was dazu sagen.
Ja, also Valiation ist auch mein Thema so ein bisschen.
In der Tat ist es so, dass wir die Instrumente anschalten und dann wollen wir
natürlich so schnell wie möglich auch sicherstellen, dass die Datenqualität auch gut ist.
Und das machen wir, indem wir bodengestützt auch, wir nennen es Kampagnen, Experimente haben.
Diese Experimente, das können bodengestützte Instrumente sein,
die so ein bisschen ähnlich sind, wie was wir auf dem Satelliten haben,
zum Beispiel ein bodengebundenes LIDAR-System, was nach oben schaut und so Wolken und Aerosole misst.
Das kann ein Radarsystem sein, was so dieselbe Signalfolge hat,
wie das, was wir auch am Satelliten fliegen. Das können auch Flugzeugexperimente sein und,
Da haben wir eine ganze Menge erlaufen, die im Prinzip auch schon kurz nach
dem Start von EarthCow auch anfangen.
Das sind Experimente, wo wir auf dem Flugzeug praktisch Instrumente fliegen,
die genauso oder ähnlich sind wie auf dem Satelliten.
Und vielleicht sagt man sich, warum machen wir es dann nicht gleich mit dem
Flugzeug? Das Flugzeug kann bloß immer eine kleine Region abtasten und sind
auch sehr teuer und sehr kompliziert aufzubauen.
Aber wir haben diese Experimente, die uns dann auch sehr schnell sagen können,
Wenn wir die Daten vergleichen, was vom Satelliten kommt, was wir von den besser
kontrollierten Systemen am Boden oder im Flugzeug haben, können wir schon ganz
schnell sagen, wie sieht die Qualität der Daten auch aus.
Sind das Flugzeuge, die es ohnehin gibt oder sind das jetzt auch Flugzeuge,
die für diese Mission konkret bestückt und ausgerüstet und vorbereitet und geflogen werden?
Das sind meistens Missionen, die Flugzeuge, die geflogen werden,
sind Forschungsflugzeuge.
Das heißt, wir haben als ESA keine eigenen Flugzeuge. Wir sind leider nicht
in derselben Situation wie NASA, die eine ganze Flotte hat.
Aber das DLR hat zum Beispiel, das DLR fliegt mit ihrem Harlow-Flugzeug,
das ist eine Gulfstream, ein hochfliegendes Flugzeug, wo zum Beispiel jetzt
ein Radarsystem und ein LIDAR-System drauf sind, die sehr ähnlich sind wie das,
was wir auch auf Satelliten fliegen.
Und die unterfliegen dann den Satelliten, das heißt, sie versuchen möglichst
das so abzustimmen, dass das Flugzeug unter dem Satelliten durchfliegt.
Natürlich ist der Satellit viel, viel schneller, der macht wusch, fliegt vorbei,
aber wir fliegen unten praktisch zum selben Zeitpunkt auch eine Linie ab und
so können wir dann zum Beispiel die Wolkensignale, die Signale von den Wolken,
die Signale von den Aerosolen auch eins zu eins vergleichen und können hier
dann schon relativ schnell feststellen,
was hier auch, wir nennen es geophysikalisch, was mit den physikalischen Parametern
okay läuft oder auch nicht okay läuft.
Muss man das noch irgendwie korrigieren? Also ist eine Messung von unten dann
wirklich genauso wie von oben?
Da hat man ja noch so ein Ozean meistens noch da drunter oder Erdmasse.
Wenn man nach oben guckt, hat man halt den Himmel.
Also die ganzen Korrekturen, die versuchen wir natürlich schon im Vorhineinfeld auch einzubauen.
Sprich, diese ganzen Algorithmen, diese ganzen Programme, die wir haben,
um diese Produkte zu produzieren, die sind schon fertig.
Die sind schon da. Wir sind noch hier ein bisschen hier und da drehen.
Da werden wir wahrscheinlich auch nie aufhören. Das wird auch nach dem Start
der Mission noch nicht beendet sein.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Korrekturen im Prinzip haben wir schon.
Und wenn alles gut geht, dann schalten wir das ein und alles funktioniert perfekt.
Ich habe noch keine Mission gesehen, wo alles perfekt funktioniert hat.
Das ist einfach so. Wir werden immer Überraschungen sehen.
Und dafür braucht man eben auch diese Messungen am Boden. Und der Vorteil von
den Instrumenten am Boden ist,
wir bauen die ein in das Flugzeug und wir messen und wir kommen zurück.
Wir können uns die Instrumente dann sofort auch wieder am Boden anschauen.
Wir können also sehr spezifisch sehen, wie die Qualität von den Flugzeug getragenen Instrumenten ist.
Die können wir einfach nehmen und, wenn wir wollten, sogar auseinanderbauen.
Das geht natürlich mit dem Satelliten nicht mehr. Das heißt,
hier können wir nicht mehr direkt reingehen und das am Instrument verändern
oder sagen wir mal sofort nachschauen, was denn vielleicht nicht funktioniert haben könnte.
Das sind Dinge, die wir natürlich mit dem Flugzeuginstrument oder mit dem Bodeninstrument machen können.
Da kann jedes Mal jemand da sein, der das Instrument repariert,
wartet, genau nachschaut, die Datenqualität auch direkt vor Ort vermisst.
Das sind Dinge, die wir ausnutzen, um eben die Qualität von den Satellitendaten zu verbessern.
Wie lange wird diese Validierungsphase dann voraussichtlich dauern müssen,
bis man sich dann sicher ist, dass es auch alles passt?
Also auch hier ist meine Erfahrung aus 20 Jahren, wir hören nie auf zu validieren. Das hört nie auf.
Achso, das wird also am Laufen im Meter?
Das wird am Laufen gehalten.
Okay, verstehe.
Unser Ziel ist es, dass wir die
ersten Daten nach sechs Monaten an die Wissenschaftler weitergeben können.
Aber das sind nur die Instrumentdaten. Das sind wirklich Daten,
wo im Prinzip auch primär die Experten damit arbeiten können.
Dann die, was wir die geophysikalischen Daten bezeichnen würden,
wie zum Beispiel Wolkenhöhe, Wolkenwasser,
Eis, Inhalte der Wolken, solche Dinge, die werden wir dann nach ungefähr neun Monaten rausgeben.
Aber das sind dann primär die
Produkte, die aufgrund von einem oder zwei Instrumenten erstellt werden.
Und dann gegen später haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Produkten,
wo wir versuchen werden, alle Instrumentdaten, diese ganzen Datenströme in ein
Produkt hineinzuführen.
Und da kommen wir vielleicht noch später zu, wenn wir von der Wissenschaft reden.
Und das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Aber all diese Schritte haben alle ihre Vor- und Nachteile und die müssen immer
gecheckt werden, ob das auch funktioniert hat.
Und deswegen die Validation werden wir durchgängig betreiben.
Am Anfang etwas intensiver, das ist normalerweise so, aber dann später auch immer noch weiter.
Wie gesagt, wir haben bei der ESA keine eigenen Flugzeuge. Wir haben auch keine
eigenen bodengestützten Instrumente notwendigerweise. Aber wir arbeiten sehr
eng mit den Wissenschaftlern zusammen.
Das heißt, wenn die eine wissenschaftliche Messkampagne haben,
dann versuchen wir immer damit auch teilzunehmen.
Und die Wissenschaftler sind sehr offen dafür, weil die wollen natürlich auch
sicherstellen, dass die Daten, die von den Satelliten kommen,
die ja auch global uns die Informationen geben, auch so gut wie möglich sind.
Schauen wir doch mal konkret, was jetzt an Bord ist.
Also was sind denn jetzt genau die Instrumente, die auf EarthCare dann die Arbeit übernehmen?
Also wenn ich es richtig sehe, sind es derer vier? Ja, das ist richtig.
Wir haben vier Instrumente, zwei aktive, also die selber Strahlen absenden und
aktiv messen können und zwei passive.
Die aktiven Sensoren ist einmal, das heißt Atlet, Atmospheric LiDAR.
Das ist ein europäisches Instrument, hauptsächlich in Toulouse gebaut,
in Frankreich. Die sind da führend.
Also ein Laserradar. Also kann man sich so vorstellen, wie wenn man eine Wohnung
besichtigt und mit so einem Laserentfernungsmesser die Größe messen will.
Das ist dasselbe Prinzip, nur ist unser Laser nicht rot, sondern der ist im
UV-Bereich, das heißt den sehen wir so nicht.
Und der hat eben den Vorteil, dass er messen kann, wo Aerosole sind,
also Staubwolken, Wasserdampf nicht, da muss ich aufpassen, genau.
Zum Beispiel über dem Meer gibt es aber auch Aerosole vom Meerwasser,
Vulkanausbrüche, Aschewolke und so weiter.
Das muss UV sein, weil die Teilchen so klein sind? Hat das was mit der...
Genau, die Aerosole sind kleiner als Wolken, also Wassertröpfchen in Wolken
und ansonsten würden die nicht reflektiert werden.
Und dieses LIDAR, was wir haben, ist ein ganz besonderes, weil wir wollen damit
nicht nur die Streuung an den Staubteilchen messen, nicht nur an Aerosolen messen,
sondern wir wollen hier auch die Streuung im Prinzip an der freien Luft messen.
Das ist das Entscheidende, dass wir hier ein System haben, was ziemlich einmalig
ist auf dem Satelliten, wo wir nicht nur die Teilchen messen,
sondern wir messen im Prinzip auch, was von der freien Atmosphäre,
von der Luft praktisch zurückgestreut wird.
Und auch deswegen haben wir das UV, weil das ist da am effektivsten.
Das ist ein bisschen ein schwieriges Konzept, aber aufgrund dieser Messung können
wir nicht nur bestimmen, da ist was streut, nicht nur, dass da Teilchen in der
Luft fliegen, sondern wir können auch noch damit sagen, was für Teilchen das sind.
Und das ist wirklich auch eine der Neuerungen von ATLIT, dieses LIDAS, das wir haben.
Dass wir nicht nur sagen können, da ist irgendwas und wir glauben,
weil es über Meer ist, dass es dann Salz ist oder weil es über der Wüste ist,
dass es dann Staub ist, sondern aufgrund dieser Messtechnik,
dass wir sowohl die Rückstreuung von den Luftteilchen, also von den Luftmolekülen haben,
wie auch die Rückstreuung von den festen Teilchen, von Aerosolen, die viel größer sind.
Diese Kombination erlaubt uns festzustellen, was denn wirklich diese Aerosole sind.
Wie gesagt, das kann Staub sein,
das kann Sand sein, das kann Produkte sein, die durch Verbrennung entstehen,
die durch Industrie entstehen und es ist wichtig für uns, dass wir diese Unterschiede kennen,
weil all diese Teilchen sich wieder anders verhalten, wenn es darum geht,
wie sie Wolken bilden oder auch wie sie dann auch wiederum klimawirksam sind.
Und das ist wirklich ein ganz, also dieses Athlet ist ein faszinierendes Instrument
das wir so noch nicht gesehen haben Ich.
Habe auch gehört, es gab ein bisschen Streit darum wie groß das ausgelegt werden soll,
dass es irgendwie mal kleiner ausgelegt werden sollte und die Wissenschaft war dagegen?
Oh ja, das gibt es natürlich immer. Es gab sogar mal den Vorschlag,
ein ganz anderes System zu bauen, weil über die lange Zeit, die wir das System
entwickelt haben, ist es natürlich so, dass aufgrund auch gewisser Randbedingungen,
wie zum Beispiel den Kosten,
neue Ideen auch entwickelt werden mussten.
Und da kamen natürlich immer auch wieder Vorschläge, ein anderes System aufzubauen
oder geht es vielleicht auch ein bisschen einfacher.
Aber die Wissenschaftler waren ganz klar, wenn wir unsere wissenschaftlichen
Ziele erreichen wollen, dann brauchen wir das System so, wie es ist.
Wir brauchen nicht ein System, wie es auch schon unsere amerikanischen Kollegen
sehr erfolgreich auch geflogen haben, sondern wir brauchen eins,
was einen deutlichen Schritt vorwärts macht.
Und das ist eben, wir nennen das das High Spectral Resolution Lidar.
Das ist wirklich ein System, wo wir nicht nur diese Rückstreuung sehen,
sondern dann im Endeffekt auch sehen können, was rückstreut.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also ich meine, das ist im Prinzip ein Laserstrahl,
der aus diesem Instrument rauskommt und der, ja was macht der denn dann?
Also der scannt dann so horizontal einen Bereich ab und empfängt gleichzeitig
das, was wieder zurückkommt.
Und daraus kann man dann jedes einzelne kleine Rußpartikelchen,
was da irgendwo über eine Strecke von ein paar hundert Kilometern fliegt, messen?
Nicht ganz, aber sehr ähnlich. Also wir scannen natürlich nichts,
sondern unser Laser, der schaut einfach nur nach unten. Der schaut einfach nur pulsiert.
Einfach nur gerade. Das sind sozusagen Schüsse. Genau. Und ich kriege dann das Echo zurück.
Und wenn ich dann eben vergleiche, wie das Licht, das ich aussende,
sich verändert hat, durch die Reflexion kann ich dann eben Rückschlüsse ziehen
auf die Art der Aerosole, was ich da getroffen habe.
Und wir können ja ein Profil erstellen. Also es ist nicht nur sozusagen,
wenn man eine Aerosolwolke hat, dann kann ich quasi auch messen, wie…,
die sozusagen ist. Ich kann nicht nur, ich sehe nicht nur, ah,
da ist was, sondern ich kann auch sagen, okay, die ist zu dick und das besteht
aus dem und dem und so weiter.
Es ist also ein vertikales Profil und dadurch, dass ich, ich fliege ja mit dem
Satellit entlang, es ist quasi wie ein Schnitt.
Wie ein Vorhang.
Ich habe mich, glaube ich.
Gerade so ein bisschen leiten lassen von, wenn LIDAR eben für so Höhenmessungen
oder sowas eingesetzt wird, da will man natürlich jede Nuance haben,
aber hier reicht es im Prinzip, wenn man quasi ein Sample nimmt.
Natürlich hätten wir gern mehr, aber es geht leider nicht. Das ist das, was wir machen.
Aber es ist trotzdem so, wir machen einen vertikalen Vorhang.
Also unter dem Satelliten sehen wir praktisch einen Vorhang von Aerosolen. Das ist die Idee.
Und bei dem, was du gefragt hattest, wie sehen wir das?
Diese Teilchen, im Prinzip haben wir drei Hauptmöglichkeiten,
wie sie mit den Lichtpulsen auf die Lichtpulse reagieren können.
Die können sie einfach bloß wegstreuen.
Sie können sie absorbieren, aufnehmen oder sie können auch, und das ist ein
bisschen schwieriger, die können auch die Polarisation des Lichtes auch verändern.
Wir kennen das alle mit Brillen, die haben zum Teil einen Polarisationsfilter
und wenn man da so ein bisschen spielt, dann sieht man, wenn man die dreht,
dass es eben Licht gibt, die in verschiedenen Ebenen vibriert, sagen wir mal.
Oder halt so Filter für Kameras. Dann hat man auch keine Spiegelung mehr,
wenn man auf dem Fach fotografiert.
Und das können wir auch. Sprich, wir können all diese Elemente von diesen Aerosolen,
und das sehen wir mit diesen Lichtpulsen, die da kommen.
Und das können wir eben in verschiedenen Höhenschichten auch machen,
sodass wir praktisch vertikale Profile bekommen von Allosolen.
Und wie gesagt, diese vertikalen Profile, die nehmen wir alle,
Die Daten haben wir alle 280 Meter oder sowas. Und dann haben wir praktisch
alle 280 Meter so ein Profil.
Und wenn wir diese ganzen Profile zusammen machen, wie so an Schnüren,
wie so an Ketten, die man so auch hat, wenn man seine Fliegen sozusagen nicht im Raum haben möchte,
so haben wir praktisch wie jede Kette, können wir zusammenhängen und dann haben
wir praktisch hier einen Vorhang von diesen Aerosol-Informationen.
Kann man jetzt wirklich, man kann jetzt an einer Stelle alle 280 Meter fokussieren
oder wie stelle ich mir das vor? Ich denke ja, das ist jetzt ein durchgehender
Strahl und ich empfange ja permanent die Reflektion aus allen Höhen gleichzeitig.
Es kommen Impulse abgeschossen, es ist an und aus. Es ist kein kontinuierlicher
Strahl und dann habe ich einfach mit der Pulsfrequenz und wie schnell ich fliege,
ungefähr 7,3 Kilometer in der Sekunde, daraus ergibt sich dann die Abtastung.
Aber wie kann man jetzt die Höhe beeinflussen? Also kann man messen,
von wo es zurückgestrahlt wurde oder kann man auf eine bestimmte Höhe ziehen?
Ich kann die Zeit messen, die es dauert, um wieder zurückzukommen.
Und dadurch kann ich dann die Höhe ableiten.
Also an der Laufzeit kann man sozusagen merken, wo jetzt was reflektiert wurde.
Genau, die Laufzeitmessung. Okay, man hat quasi immer nur eine Reflektion,
die man jetzt gerade zur Kenntnis nimmt, aber davon sehr viele.
Genau, und dann schaue ich mir noch das Spektrum an, von dem Licht,
das zurückkommt und da kann ich dann eben Rückschlüsse sie drüber ziehen,
was ich da tatsächlich gemessen habe.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Also das Athlet ist, sagen wir mal, schon mal ein ganz wichtiges
Teil hier auf diesem Apparat.
Das ist sozusagen schon das wichtigste Instrument, kann man sagen?
Also man ist wahrscheinlich alle irgendwie wichtig.
Ja, es deckt halt genau die Hälfte ab, sozusagen, weil,
der Laser geht durch, kann Aerosolprofile messen, Aber bei Wolken sieht er eigentlich
nur die Oberfläche. Der kann die Wolke nicht durchdringen.
Und da kommt das japanische Instrument ins Spiel. Das misst den Mikrowellenbereich.
Heißt Cloud Profiling Radar, also Wolkenprofil Radar.
Und das kann eben dasselbe, was wir mit den Agressoren machen,
mit dem Athlet. Das kann ein Profil von den Wolken erstellen.
Weil das da eben die auch durchdringt. Und zusätzlich noch, und das ist wirklich
das Besondere dabei, das hat eine Doppler-Messfunktion.
Doppler bedeutet, es kann Bewegungen, vertikale Bewegungen innerhalb der Wolke
messen mit einer gewissen Genauigkeit.
Ich glaube, ein Meter pro Sekunde ist das Ziel.
Und das kann man sich natürlich, das ist klar, zum Beispiel Regen.
Ich kann also nicht nur ein Profil der Wolke erstellen, sondern ich kann auch
sagen, was passiert denn in der Wolke gerade? Regnet es da oder nicht?
Gibt es andere Bewegungen? Und das kann man sich natürlich auch vorstellen,
dass das dann für Klimamodelle, aber auch für die Wettervorhersage natürlich auch interessant ist.
Es geht noch weiter, diese Fallgeschwindigkeit, die wir messen.
Was wir messen, ist im Prinzip, wie schnell fallen die Tröpfchen,
wie schnell fällt der Regen, wie schnell fällt aber auch das Eis.
Und je nachdem, wie schnell die fallen, das hängt davon ab, wie die aufgebaut sind.
Was für Kristalle haben wir, wie groß sind die Tröpfchen etc.
Das heißt, es geht nicht nur darum, dass wir am Schluss eine Regenrate haben,
sondern wir können auch mit dieser Information besser bestimmen,
was für eine Art von Wolkentröpfchengröße zum Beispiel wir haben oder was für
eine Art von Eis wir haben.
Und das sind alles wichtige Dinge, die wieder für Klima entscheidend sind.
Was heißt, was für eine Art von Eis? Also ob es Schnee oder Hagel ist?
Also Hagel dürfen wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr sehen, weil der ist sehr,
sehr dicht. Aber wir können die Art der Kristalle sehen.
Wenn große Kristalle oder kleine Kristalle, die fallen unterschiedlich schnell.
Und das können wir zum Beispiel mit diesen Messungen auch bestimmen.
Also wir können praktisch noch besser sagen, wie die Wolke aufgebaut ist.
Wir können natürlich nicht sagen, der Kristall sieht so oder so aus,
aber wir haben eine bessere Annahme dazu.
Und das heißt, das Cloud-Programming-Radar und das ATLIT, die ergänzen sich sozusagen.
Das ist, um so einen holistischen Blick reinzubekommen, sowohl eine Vorstellung
davon zu haben, woraus ist es gemacht, aber auch, was bewegt sich da drin.
Was ist da jetzt sozusagen der vermutlich wirkliche Durchbruch,
was im Vergleich zu den anderen Missionen, mit denen man bisher Wolken hat beobachten können,
was gewinnt man jetzt hier an Informationen, die so in der Qualität vielleicht
oder überhaupt so noch gar nicht da waren?
Also eine ist die Qualität, das ist ganz klar. Die Systeme sind so genau wie
wahrscheinlich keines davor. Das ist die eine Seite.
Genauigkeit ist der eine Punkt, aber auch die Unterschiedlichkeit der Dinge,
die wir sehen können. Wir haben es gerade schon bei dem Update auch gesagt gehabt,
dass dieses spezielle LIDAR eben nicht nur die Rückstreuung erkennt,
sondern dass wir eben mit all den Informationen auch sagen können, was es ist.
Und dasselbe natürlich auch mit dem Radar, das hatten wir ja auch eben,
dass wir eben auch noch präziser sagen können, was für eine Art von Wolkenteilchen,
Eisteilchen hier in der Wolke sind. Und das zusammenzubringen, ist eben entscheidend.
Hier in unserem Fall haben wir die Systeme auf einem Satelliten.
Das heißt, wir können sicherstellen, dass die beiden Instrumente sich genau
dieselbe Szene anschauen.
Die schauen sich genau dieselben Wolken an, die schauen sich genau dieselben Aerosole an.
Das CPR, das Radar sieht keine Aerosole, aber man sieht immer dasselbe.
Und das ist also auch schon mal ein ganz wichtiges Element. Wir können die Datenströme
zusammenbringen. Wir wissen genau, wie die zusammengehören.
Und das ist wirklich der neue Schritt, den wir bisher noch nicht so gehabt haben.
Wir können also noch besser für die Wissenschaftler diese Charakterisierung
der Wolken und der Aerosol auch darstellen.
Jetzt gibt es ja noch zwei Instrumente, die haben wir noch nicht erwähnt, die passiv sind.
Genau, also das erste passive Instrument ist im Prinzip eine Art Fotokamera,
Multispectral Imager heißt es.
Das ist eine Streifenkamera, der scannt so einen Streifen ab,
der ist 150 Kilometer breit, Das ist also deutlich breiter als der Fußabdruck
der anderen aktiven Instrumente.
Das ist nämlich 30 Meter für den LIDAR und ungefähr ein Kilometer für den Radar.
Also sehr schmal. Da kann man sich auch vorstellen, dass zum Beispiel,
wenn man eine Bodenstation hat, ist es gar nicht so wahrscheinlich,
dass man da getroffen wird.
Und deswegen haben wir auch die Flugzeugkampagnen, um einfach mehr Messungen zu haben.
Wie groß ist denn der Abstand zwischen zwei Durchläufen? Also wenn jetzt man
einmal über den Nordpol nochmal rüberkommt?
Also wenn man das mal wieder am selben Punkt auf der Erde vorbeifliegt, das ist 25 Tage.
Und wie weit ist sozusagen die Linie?
Die Linie, das kommt darauf an, wo man ist auf der Erde. Am Pol sind sie natürlich
näher zusammen, am Äquator, das ist über 1000 Kilometer.
1000 Kilometer pro Durchlauf, okay.
Also ziemlich groß eigentlich.
Das heißt, auch mit diesen Imagern hat man auch nur eine Linie?
Da geht es darum, Kontextinformationen zu bekommen.
Also das MSI hat sieben Kanäle, sowohl Infrarot als auch im sichtbaren Bereich.
Und das unterstützt einfach die Klassifizierung sowohl von den Aerosolen als auch von den Wolken.
Da kann man sagen, was für Wolken, wo ist es, was passiert da drumherum.
Wir kriegen ja nur ein vertikales Profil mit den aktiven Sensoren.
Und die Daten von dem Imager werden dann auch verwendet, um dann eine 3D-Wolken-
und Aerosol-Szene zu berechnen und dann mit den Messungen vom dritten Instrument, das ist das Radiometer,
zu vergleichen, um zu sehen, ob unsere Annahmen, die wir haben über Aerosole
und Wolken, ob die stimmen tatsächlich. Das dritte Instrument ist ein Radiometer.
Dieser Imager, ich meine, der ist ja passiv, das heißt, er kriegt ja nur, was ihm geliefert wird.
So, da sieht man ja nicht nur Wolken, sondern da sieht man ja alles sozusagen.
Oder ist das so ausgelegt, dass man nur Wolken...
Also man sieht da die komplette Strahlung, also in den Bändern eben die gesamte
Strahlung, die zurückkommt.
Also es trägt dann auch für die Berechnung der Strahlungsbilanz trägt der auch
bei. Aber da sieht man ja alles.
Also sieht man auch Wasser.
Erde, Ozean, alles, was eben unterschiedliche, auch thermische Signaturen...
Es ist praktisch wie ein klassischer Imager. Wir haben zum Beispiel Sentinel-2
oder Spotty Marsh, die wirklich dazu da sind, nur einfach die Erde zu beobachten.
Für die sind in der Tat Wolken und Aerosole, was die am liebsten herausfiltern wollen.
Das ist ganz klar. Aber im Prinzip sind diese Imager, die wir haben, ist genau das auch.
Es ist eine Kamera, was praktisch nur den Boden sich von oben aus anschaut und
die Wolken natürlich dazwischen drin sind. Aber für uns ist das entscheidend,
weil wir wollen uns genau auf diese Wolken und auf die Aerosole auch konzentrieren.
Okay, so, dann kommen wir zum vierten Instrument und dem letzten Instrument, das ist das Radiometer.
Breitbandradiometer heißt das, weil das im Prinzip das gesamte Spektrum abdeckt,
das auch das MSI abdeckt, also wirklich vom Infrarot bis dann über den sichtbaren
Bereich und beinahe fast bis in die Mikrowellen, glaube ich.
Es geht relativ weit raus und da ist der Fußabdruck relativ groß, 10 Kilometer.
Das ist ein Pixel. Man schaut dann direkt unter den Satellit zurück und nach vorne.
Da werden dann drei Messungen kombiniert, um ein besseres Signal-Rausch-Verhältnis zu haben.
Und das Instrument misst eben die Strahlung, die am Satellitenort ankommt und das dient dann dazu,
die Messungen, die Annahmen, die man macht über Aerosole und Wolken,
wie die die Strahlung der Sonne reflektieren, absorbieren und so weiter, zu überprüfen.
Wir berechnen dann in 3D-Szene, 10 mal 10 mal 10 Kilometer, Also eine Art Würfel,
wo wir sagen, okay, das ist die aktuelle Situation.
Wir haben bestimmte Annahmen, wie sich diese Arten von Wolken und Aerosolen
verhalten, was die Strahlung der Sonne angeht.
Und wenn wir recht haben, dann müsste die und die Strahlung in dem Moment am
Ort des Satelliten ankommen.
Und das können wir mit dem Radiometer dann vergleichen.
Da wird es Unterschiede geben und da kann Thorsten noch mehr dazu sagen.
Das ist natürlich dann nicht ganz so einfach zu sagen, okay,
Moment mal, wo ist denn jetzt der Fehler?
Weil das kann natürlich, habe ich meinen Radiometer richtig kalibriert?
Habe ich meine Instrumente richtig kalibriert?
Habe ich bei der Prozessierung alles richtig gemacht und so?
Das ist dann auf jeden Fall eine der großen Herausforderungen der Mission.
Aber das macht es eben auch einzigartig. Weil da kann ich an einem Ort zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt tatsächlich messbar überprüfen, meine Annahmen.
Haben, wo ich sonst natürlich immer andere Plattformen, Sensoren usw.
Brauche und das ist bei EarthCare eben nicht der Fall. Da haben wir alles an
einem Ort auf einem Satelliten.
Also vielleicht noch auf das BBA ganz kurz zurückzukommen. Wir messen da in zwei Kanälen.
Wir messen einmal, wie du schon gesagt hast, vom UV, das thermische Infrarot.
Das ist der Bereich, wo die meiste Energie in das Erdsystem von der Sonne reingestrahlt
wird und wo wir auch wieder abstrahlen.
Das heißt, wir wollen praktisch hier einmal den gesamten Bereich abmessen,
um zu sehen, wie viel Energie da ist.
Wird dann weggestrahlt. Und dann haben wir noch einen kleineren Bereich,
der nur das Solare betrifft, also sprich nur die Wellenlänge sich anschaut,
die wir von der Sonne bekommen, die auch wieder von der Erde abreflektiert werden.
Das heißt, wir haben hier praktisch Solaris, was wir Solare,
Sonneneinstrahlung nennen, und die thermische Strahlung, die messen wir mit dem.
Und das ist richtig, wir haben drei Direktionen. Und wichtig ist auch zu verstehen,
dass die Erde nicht homogen abstrahlt.
Es ist also nicht so, dass wir immer nur nach oben gleichmäßig abstrahlen,
sondern je nachdem, was wir für Verhältnisse auf dem Boden haben,
das hängt mit der Bodenbeschaffenheit ab, das hängt mit der Vegetation ab,
kann die Strahlung durchaus nicht isotrop sein.
Die kann durchaus in die eine Richtung mehr, seitlich mehr als nach oben oder
in die andere Richtung abgestrahlt werden.
Deswegen ist es auch für uns wichtig, dass wir diese drei Blickwinkel haben.
Am liebsten hätten wir natürlich noch viel, viel mehr, das ist klar,
aber drei sind schon mal ein ganz guter Ansatzpunkt. Und damit können wir dann
besser das Abstrahlen von der Erde, die Deflektion der Sonnenstrahlung,
des Sonnenlichts besser bestimmen.
Und dann kann man natürlich auch die Differenz bilden. In dem Moment,
wo man über eine Wolke rüberfliegt,
sieht man ja, okay, eben gerade kam noch so viel Strahlung, jetzt haben wir
eine Wolke mit der und der Beschaffenheit und auf einmal fehlt uns diese Menge
an Energie in diesem thermischen Bereich.
Genau, wir werden dann natürlich sehen, dass wenn die Sonne scheint,
wir messen ja nicht nur, wenn die Sonne scheint, sondern dadurch,
dass wir auch aktive Instrumente haben, können wir natürlich auch auf der Sonne...
Also die Sonne scheint ja immer. Die Sonne scheint immer.
Aber nicht immer da, wo der Satellit ist. Das heißt, wir umkreisen ja die Erde
und wir haben auch eine dunkle Seite.
Wir gehen natürlich auch in die Eclipse-Seite und auch da können wir trotzdem
noch messen mit den Instrumenten. Das ist auch wichtig, deswegen sind aktive
Instrumente auch so wichtig für uns.
Mit dem Imager wird es ein bisschen schwieriger, aber auch der kann die thermischen
Messungen immer noch durchführen.
Und das ist also auch diese Kombination aus dem Messsystem ist hier wieder entscheidend.
Aber der sonnensynchrone Orbit soll ja auch eigentlich sicherstellen,
dass man die Sonne immer sieht.
Fast, wie gesagt, weil die Erdachse ja nicht ganz senkrecht steht zur Ekliptik,
ändert sich das mit den Jahreszeiten leicht.
Es gibt dann Jahreszeiten, wo wir ein paar Minuten Eklipse haben und es gibt
natürlich im Sommer fliegt man dann nur in der Sonne.
Das ändert sich im Laufe des Jahres um wenig, aber ja, also wir werden auch
Daten im Schatten haben.
Genau, und auf der einen Seite ist es halt immer 14 Uhr und auf der anderen
Seite ist es natürlich nicht 14 Uhr.
Genau.
Das muss man auch erstmal im Kopf kriegen. Okay, also das waren sozusagen die Instrumente.
Das ist sozusagen das ganze Paket. Stimmt das, dass der insgesamt sehr eng gebaut
ist und auch so eine gewisse Stromlinie Linienförmigkeit noch aufweist. Warum ist das so?
Das sieht man, ist auch äußerlich dann erkennbar.
An dem Satellit, 400 Kilometer ist schon so niedrig, dass der Luftwiderstand eine Rolle spielt.
Und da ist die Restatmosphäre noch so dicht, dass man auch die normalen Satelliten,
sind ja eigentlich dunkel, haben eine dunkle Außenhaut.
Wir haben eine weiße Außenhaut. Oder golden, oder je nachdem.
Und wir haben eine weiße Außenhaut. Das ist eine andere Oberfläche,
die eben mit der Restatmosphäre besser umgehen kann, die sich dann nicht sozusagen kaputt geht.
Wäre die Atmosphäre zu dicht für eine normale Beschichtung, die würde sich dann
abnutzen, kann man sagen.
Und wenn man den Satellit anschaut, der ist auch auf Stromlinienform optimiert.
Deswegen ist auch das Solarpanel nach hinten.
Das ist eine langgestreckte Form. und die Oberfläche, die man dem Luftwiderstand aussetzt, minimiert.
Also das, und muss, also schlank ist relativ,
ja, ist immer noch relativ groß, aber man hat wirklich versucht,
das zu optimieren und wenn man zum Beispiel in das LIDA-Instrument reinschaut,
dann wird einem klar, dass sie da wirklich alles so dicht gepackt gemacht haben,
wie nur möglich, was natürlich auch dann,
es ist schwierig, sowas zu bauen, weil, darf man auch nicht vergessen,
da geht es ja auch um quasi die Abwärme, muss man ja loswerden und so weiter,
das ist ja dann alles nicht so einfach im Weltraum.
Gibt es keine Luftkühlung in dem Sinn und das war auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung.
Auch vom Ingenieurtechnischen das so auf dem zur Verfügung stehenden Volumen
zum Funktionieren zu bringen.
Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, warum Weiß jetzt hilft gegen Luft?
Das ist eine andere Oberfläche einfach, die nicht reagiert mit der Restatmosphäre
und sich nicht kaputt geht dabei.
Also die aus was besteht dann? Was ist das für ein Material?
Das ist ein ein Stoff. Das ist ein Stoff, der das, was wir haben in der Höhe,
ist atomarer Sauerstoff.
Und der atomare Sauerstoff ist sehr aggressiv.
Und das im Prinzip ist das wie ein Stoff, der in dem Fall eben die Oxidierung,
der Teile verhindert, dadurch, dass es eben auf der Oberfläche passiert.
Was wir normalerweise fänden, Mylar oder ähnliche Produkte, die werden angegriffen.
Aber das ist kein Problem.
Diese Satelliten fliegen auf 800 Kilometer Höhe. Da ist fast keine Atmosphäre mehr.
Wenn wir weiter unten sind, haben wir eben immer noch diese,
wie Björn gerade gesagt hat, die Restatmosphäre.
Und dieser atomare Sauerstoff, der wird praktisch auf dieser Oberfläche absorbiert,
ohne dass er zum Schaden führt.
Hm, also ich meine 400 Kilometer, das ist ja eigentlich schon richtig Weltraum.
Also sagt man ja, ab 100 Kilometer gilt, also man war im All,
wenn man 100 Kilometer hoch war.
Das ist ja so eine Definitionsfrage und man kann natürlich auch sagen,
das hört ja nie auf, der Einfluss der Erde. Aber bei 400 Kilometern ist nicht
viel los, da kann man nicht atmen, aber da ist eben auch nicht leer.
Genau, das kann man so sagen.
Natürlich ist es klar, dass es nicht so ein Luftwiderstand ist,
wie wenn man sich in der Atmosphäre bewegt, wo das quasi eher eine Strömung ist.
Sondern es sind einzelne Teile, die auf den Satelliten treffen.
Aber es sind trotzdem genug, um so einen Effekt zu haben, dass man eben eine
besondere Beschichtung haben muss. Das war zum Beispiel bei unserer Schwerefeldmission
Goetje, die ist ja auf 250 Kilometer geflogen.
Die hat dieselbe, die war auch weiß, der Satellit, genau deswegen.
Um eben auch der Restatmosphäre, sagen wir mal, standhalten zu können.
Weil das, was noch rumfliegt, ist dann halt vor allem Sauerstoff.
Heißt Atomarer Sauerstoff.
Sonst nichts oder nur das ist das Problem sozusagen.
Das ist das Problem.
Weil der besonders aggressiv ist.
Der wird ja immer oxidierend. Genau. Der Name schon sagt.
Genau. Und wenn es so viel rumoxidiert, dann ist ja alles verrostet. Das will man nicht.
Okay, das heißt, mit weißem Stoff kann man sich da schützen.
Ist ja auch sehr elegant auf eine gewisse Art und Weise.
In der Tat.
Gekleidet im Orbit.
Gut.
Dann kommen wir noch mal so ein bisschen auf den Nutzen und wie man jetzt sozusagen
daraus auch wirklich wissenschaftliches Kapital schlagen kann.
Also haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen, es geht hier vor allem erstmal
um Grundlagen, um erstmal Daten zu sammeln,
die so noch nicht haben gemessen werden können, weil man einfach dieses Instrument
so in der Form noch nicht hatte.
Und klar, da kommen viel Rohdaten raus,
die wahrscheinlich auch als solche erstmal weitergereicht werden und dann werden
irgendwelche Wissenschaftler irgendwas damit machen, aber es gibt ja jetzt gewisse
Erwartungshaltungen, die ja dann letzten Endes auch in das Design hier mit eingeflossen sind.
Das klang ja schon so ein bisschen an, so Klimamodelle teilen ja,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch so diese Gesamtatmosphäre halt in solche Voxel,
in solche Volumenpixel sozusagen auf und man versucht in irgendeiner Form abzubilden, was ist da los,
was ist da drin, was macht das, wie kalt ist das, wie nass ist das und so weiter.
Und das ist ja hier dann sozusagen so ein neues zusätzliches Mosaiksteinchen
für diese Gesamtmodelle.
Inwiefern ist denn jetzt die Mission da auch wirklich mit solchen Fragen beschäftigt
oder ist das einfach nur ein Datenlieferant und man lässt den Kram woanders machen?
Also das ist gerade bei Earthquake genau umgekehrt. Hier ist die wissenschaftliche
Frage in der Tat in das System mit reingebaut worden.
Weil die Frage, die sich uns stellt, ist natürlich, wie Wolken und Aerosole
auf den Strahlungshaushalt der Erde einwirkt.
Und das ist wirklich, wo wir unseren Fokus drauf haben, ist,
wie können wir das besser charakterisieren.
Wir alle sind uns klar, dass...
Dass Klimagase schädlich sind, dass sie zur Wärmung führen. Das sind alles Dinge, die bekannt sind.
Und in dem Fall sind diese, das Wissen ist eigentlich relativ klar,
das ist uns relativ bekannt.
Also es gibt jetzt hier nichts Geheimnisvolles an Treibhausgasen.
Wir müssen natürlich wissen, wo sie herkommen, wie sie entstehen,
wie man sie verhindern kann.
Das ist alles ganz klar. Aber die physikalische Frage dahinter ist nicht wirklich so unbekannt.
Das sind Prozesse, die wir kennen, schon seit langem. Bei Wolken ist es durchaus
anders. Dadurch, dass Wolken so divers mit dem Klima interagieren,
sind da immer noch viele Fragen offen.
Und das ist, weswegen wir EarthCare haben. Deswegen versuchen wir eben all diese
Elemente auch zusammenzubringen.
Das Ziel von EarthCare ist es, den Strahlungshaushalt der Erde besser zu bestimmen
und wie es mit Aerosolen und auch mit Wolken interagiert.
Das ist das Ziel. Und das ist, was wir messen mit dem Satelliten,
mit dem LIDAR, mit dem Radar, auch mit der Kamera, die uns die Wolkenbilder
liefert und dann am Schluss auch mit dem Radiometer.
Und was wir versuchen, ist festzustellen, wie die Abstrahlung durch Wolken und
Aerosole entsteht, sozusagen.
Das heißt, wir versuchen hier so die Abstrahlung besser festzustellen.
Vielleicht beginne ich mal von der Fragestellung als solches.
Wir wissen zum Beispiel aus den Klimaforschungsberichten, dass Wolken und Aerosole
primär zum Kühlen des Klimas beitragen.
Treibhausgase erwärmen, aber in den letzten Jahren durch die Aktivitäten von
Menschen seit der Industrialisierung haben wir so viele Aerosole durch Verbrennungsprozesse
in die Atmosphäre eingetragen,
dass es insgesamt dazu geführt hat, dass wir auf der Seite sogar einen Kühlen
der Atmosphäre beigetragen haben.
Das heißt, wir haben mehr Wolken, wir haben andere Wolken, wir haben die Aerosole.
Die streuen mehr Licht zurück, als sie Energie im System festhalten.
Und die Frage ist, wie verändert sich das auch in der Zukunft?
Zum einen, was passiert hier im Moment und wie verändert sich das in der Zukunft?
Und deswegen versuchen wir, all diese Elemente zusammenzutragen mit den Aerosolen und den Wolken.
Es gibt Vorhersagen, die ganz klar sind, dass in einem veränderten Klima der
kühlende Einfluss von Aerosolen und Wolken geringer wird.
Das heißt, es ist eine Fragestellung auch der Klimavorhersage.
Das heißt, wir müssen all diese Prozesse auch besser verstehen.
Und hier trägt auch der Satellit wieder dazu bei. Das heißt,
wir versuchen wirklich, das in ein System zu integrieren.
Björn hat es vorhin schon ein bisschen angedeutet. Wir haben auf der einen Seite
die aktiven Instrumente und die Kamera, die uns Informationen über die Wolken
geben, über die Aerosole geben.
Und all das bauen wir zusammen zu einem dreidimensionalen Modell,
in dem wir mit all unserem Wissen, was wir wissenschaftlich haben,
versuchen, den Strahlungshaushalt zu bestimmen.
Also wir versuchen praktisch alles, was wir wissen, in die Modelle mit den neuen Daten einzufügen.
Und daraus können wir berechnen, wie viel Strahlung reflektiert wird,
wie viel in der Atmosphäre festgehalten wird.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir das Breitbandradiometer, was uns direkt auch
diese Messung ermöglicht.
Und das ist das wirklich Coole an der Mission, dass wir auf der einen Seite
mit den aktiven Instrumenten und unserem wissenschaftlichen Wissen,
das Wissen, was wir haben.
Einen Strahlungshaushalt berechnen
können, den wir dann direkt mit dem Breitbandradiometer abschätzen können.
Wenn unsere Berechnungen genau dieselben sind wie das, was uns das Radiometer
sagt, dann können wir eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass wir ziemlich viel von
der Atmosphäre verstehen.
Dann wissen wir, wie Wolken, Aerosole und der Strahlungshaushalt zusammenhängen.
Aber wir sind uns ziemlich sicher, dass wir Unterschiede sehen werden.
Und wenn wir unseren Daten vertrauen können, das machen wir,
wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, durch die Validierung der Daten,
durch die Kalibrierung der Daten.
Wenn wir den Daten vertrauen und wenn wir vertrauen, dass alles unser Wissen,
was wir haben, in den Modellen besteht und wir vergleichen es dann mit diesen
direkten Messungen, das ist da, wo dann wirklich the magic happens.
Das ist da, wo dann wirklich das passiert, was wir eigentlich wissen wollen.
Wenn wir Unterschiede sehen und dann zurückverfolgen, wo unser Verständnis von
Aerosolen und Wolken vielleicht dann doch nicht so richtig ist,
wo wir vielleicht doch unsere Ideen abgleichen müssen, Wo wir physikalische
Prozesse vielleicht nicht ganz hundertprozentig verstehen. Das ist das, wo wir hinwollen.
Aber sehe ich das richtig, dass das jetzt bei Earthcare ein bisschen anders
organisiert ist mit der Wissenschaft, als man das jetzt zum Beispiel bei James Webb hat?
James Webb nimmt halt Bilder auf und dann werden die halt dahin geschoben,
wo sie beauftragt wurden,
dass hier bei Earthcare es eher ein wirklich missionsnahes Wissenschaftsteam
gibt, was sich um ganz konkrete Fragestellungen kümmert und sozusagen unmittelbar
mit dieser Maschine arbeitet.
Weil das ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt normal oder ist das auch bei anderen Missionen oft so?
Also bei den Erdmacht, bei unseren Earth Explorer Missionen ist es schon sehr
häufig so, dass das ganz klar für eine wissenschaftliche Community gemacht worden ist.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, es ist für ein paar Leute gemacht,
aber es gibt eine ganze Community, die
sich auch hier speziell auf die wissenschaftlichen Fragen konzentriert.
Wir haben gesehen, dass praktisch bei allen unseren Erdbeobachtungssatelliten,
bei unseren Earth Explorern oder auch bei den Sentinels oder auch bei den meteorologischen
Missionen, dass da immer wieder neue Fragestellungen, an die wir gar nicht gedacht
haben, auch dann beantwortet werden können oder neue Applikationen entwickelt werden.
Aber im Prinzip ist es natürlich schon so, dass wir hier eine ganz klare Fragestellung
haben, die in den Klimabereich hineinfällt.
Wie du schon gesagt hast, wir haben unser Core-Team an Wissenschaftlern,
die zum Beispiel auch für die Entwicklung der Algorithmen auch verantwortlich sind.
Aber dann haben wir einen großen Kreis an Klimawissenschaftlern,
die auf diese Daten warten.
Wir hatten vor ein paar Monaten im November einen Workshop, also eine Konferenz
in Frascati, wo wir vor dem Launch die Wissenschaftler eingeladen haben,
ihre Wissenschaft, die in dem Bereich ist, auch zu präsentieren.
Also Frascati ist in Essien.
Ist in Italien. Und die Rückmeldung, die wir bekommen hatten von den Wissenschaftlern
war, ja, EarthCare ist immer noch eine Vision, die wir dringend brauchen.
Und uns hat vielleicht sogar diese Verzögerung der Entwicklung auch in dem Sinne
geholfen, dass die Modelle, die die Klimawissenschaftler entwickelt haben,
vor zehn Jahren waren die noch auf einer Skala, wo die eine Vox ist,
die du gesagt hast, wo die horizontale Auflösung, die war eher so im mehrere-zehn-Kilometer-Bereich.
Dank der Rechenkapazitäten, die wir heute haben und auch dem besseren Verständnis,
gehen diese Modelle immer mehr in, was wir sagen, in einem Kilometer-Bereich.
Das heißt, wir können praktisch die Erde unterteilen in Kilometer-Voxels oder
in Gitter, die horizontal ungefähr in Kilometer sind.
Und das passt jetzt natürlich auch wieder sehr gut mit den Messungen von EarthCare auch überein.
Das heißt, wir können hier in einer relativ direkten Art und Weise die Earth-Care-Messungen
auch in die Klimamodelle übertragen, um auch hier besser zu verstehen,
wie deren Physik funktioniert.
In welche Höhe gehen diese Modelle?
Die Modelle, die gehen bis in 20, 30 Kilometer Höhe, die sind meistens so aufgebaut,
dass du unten eine höhere Auflösung hast, wir nennen es die Troposphäre,
das heißt die untersten, sagen wir mal 8 bis 15 Kilometer,
die sind höher aufgelöst, da kann es dann ein paar hundert Meter sein und dann
desto höher wir gehen, desto gröber aufgelöst sind die und das hängt dann davon
ab, von welchem Modell wir da reden,
aber meistens haben die noch die Stratosphäre, das kann bis in die mittlere
Stratosphäre gehen, also sprich so, sagen wir mal bis 30 Kilometer,
das kann auch manchmal ein bisschen höher gehen. Aber das hängt dann wirklich sehr vom Modell ab.
EarthCare kann dazu Daten liefern. Wir können die gesamte, wir sagen mal die
Troposphäre und die Stratosphäre abdecken, das heißt die untersten,
was sind das, 12 bis 15 Kilometer.
Da können wir Daten direkt an die Modelle und auch an die Wissenschaftler liefern.
Das heißt, wenn du sagst, ja, wir haben natürlich ein Team, was ganz dezidiert
uns auch unterstützt in der Entwicklung der Mission von Anfang an.
Also wir würden nie auf unserer Seite eine Mission entwickeln,
ohne dass wir eine wissenschaftliche Betreuung auch dabei haben.
Es ist auch ein bisschen anders wie bei den Instrumenten, die in dem Space Science
Bereich der ESA entstehen,
wo die Instrumente direkt von wissenschaftlichen Teams praktisch geliefert werden
und die dann auch primär die Auswertung machen.
Bei der Erdbeeraufzugsposition, die wir haben, bauen wir die Instrumente und
müssen sicherstellen, dass wir auch damit einen möglichst weiten Bereich,
einen möglichst großen Bereich an wissenschaftlicher Community,
an wissenschaftlichen Teams auch ansprechen.
Und dementsprechend, wie gesagt, wir haben Core, aber wir haben hunderte von
Wissenschaftlern, die auch mit den Daten weiterarbeiten werden.
Das ist für uns ganz wichtig, dass wir nicht nur hier eine Vision bauen,
die für eine Nische ist, sondern wirklich was, was auch global verwendet wird.
Wir arbeiten zusammen nicht nur mit europäischen Wissenschaftlern und mit den
Japanern, wie wir auch vorhin schon erwähnt haben.
Wir haben hier eine sehr enge Zusammenarbeit, aber auch mit unseren amerikanischen Kollegen.
Und eigentlich ist es eine globale Zusammenarbeit, die wir haben und noch weiter ausbauen.
Wie viele Voxels sind das dann so in modernen Klimamodellen,
die da mittlerweile dann bei rauskommen mit dieser höheren Auflösung?
Also wie feingliedrig ist das?
Ich habe jetzt keine Rechnung im Kopf angestellt, weil da scheitert man natürlich sofort wieder dran.
Also ich möchte jetzt auch da keine Zahl geben. Das sind sehr,
sehr, sehr viele. Wir haben uns überlegt.
Klar, die Erde ist groß.
Die Erde ist groß.
Die Voxels sind klein. Eine komplette Zahl habe ich jetzt auch nicht im Kopf.
Das würde ich jetzt auch nicht hinbekommen. Ich kann es ehrlich gestehen,
da müsste ich auch bloß mit dem Taschenrechner, dann könnten wir das vielleicht
dann irgendwie ausrechnen.
Ich speichere das mal unter eigentlich eine gute Frage gewesen.
Eine gute Frage kann ich dir leider nicht so schnell beantworten.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall mehr geworden und es ist halt auch um einen Faktor,
also um Größenordnung sozusagen gestiegen.
Um Größenordnungen, das ist wirklich um Größenordnung gestiegen.
Also wenn das so auf einmal ein Kilometer ist, wo vorher zehn ist,
das ist natürlich eine totale Datenexplosion.
Ist das sozusagen das Einzige, was sich an den Klimamodellen verbessert oder gibt es auch...
Nennenswert vielmehr Parameter, die sozusagen so einem Voxel zugeordnet werden?
Was in diesen Modellen gemacht wird, ist, dass man manche Prozesse,
die kann man nicht auflösen, die kann man nicht mit diesen Gittern direkt vermessen.
Du musst dir nur vorstellen, du nimmst, nehmen wir mal wieder unser Sommergewitter.
Dieses Sommergewitter, das hat vielleicht eine Skala von, ach sagen wir mal,
horizontal 10 auf 10 Kilometer. Machen wir ein kleines Gewitter.
Dieses Gewitter konnte man früher zum Beispiel in diesen Modellen gar nicht
auflösen, weil die haben eine Gitterweite von 10 Kilometern gehabt.
Das heißt, alles, was da drin passiert, wurde ein Gewitterwurzel.
Um dann den vertikalen Prozess auch irgendwo darzustellen oder auch dann den
Strahlungsprozess darzustellen, dazu hat man dann Parametrisierung verwendet.
Das heißt, man hat gesagt, okay, wir wissen, was da für Wind,
Wetter, Wasser drin ist Und aufgrund der Beobachtung sagen wir,
okay, wir transportieren jetzt mal was nach oben.
Die neuen Modelle können wirklich auch diese Wolken schon direkt auflösen.
Noch nicht auf dem Kilometerbereich, aber die werden immer besser.
Sodass wir praktisch jetzt direkt für jeden Gitterpunkt in diesem Gewitter auch
direkt ausmessen können, was ist die Windgeschwindigkeit, ist es ein Aufwind,
ist es ein Abwind, wie viel Eis, wie viel Schnee, wie viel Wasser, was ist die Temperatur.
Das heißt, wir können das immer besser auch auflösen. Und da,
um wieder den Dreh auf EarthScape zu machen, können wir auch direkt Daten liefern.
Das heißt, was vor zehn Jahren vielleicht in eine Parametrisierung reingegangen
wäre, mit all ihren Annahmen, geht jetzt direkt in diese Modelle mit ein.
Dadurch, dass wir eben jetzt zum einen diese Messung zur Verfügung haben,
aber auch diese höhere Auflösung.
Und da nimmt natürlich auch sehr viel, sagen wir mal, uns heraus.
Das heißt, die Modelle werden konkreter werden.
Die Modelle werden konkreter.
Sie werden mit echten Daten beliefert, wo man vorher gesagt hat,
können wir die messen, haben wir auch nicht die Auflösung für,
aber so Pi mal Daumen irgendwie, da legen wir jetzt mal hier Faktor und Skala
rein, dann passt das schon irgendwie.
Wenn wir Pi mal Daumen sein würden, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich mit vielen
meiner Modellierungskollegen Schwierigkeiten bekommen. Das sind auch sehr komplexe Parametrisierungen.
Aber im Prinzip ist es das.
Aber im Prinzip ist das. Und desto höher aufgelöst wir werden,
desto besser können wir natürlich auch all diese Prozesse auch bestimmen und
können natürlich dann auch besser diesen Strahlungshaushalt auch ausreichen.
Sprich, wie viel Strahlung wird jetzt von den Wolken reflektiert,
wie viel wird zurückgehalten.
Und die Wolken waren bisher eigentlich so ein bisschen so ein Unsicherheitsfaktor
in dieser ganzen Klimageschichte.
Und das ist sozusagen jetzt auch ein Ziel vom Unsicherheitsfaktor zum Datenlieferanten zu werden.
Genau, das ist eben eines der Ziele. Wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte,
Wolken und Aerosole, insbesondere die Wolken, sind sogar ein Kühlungsfaktor.
Und es war immer klar, dass es wahrscheinlich in die Richtung geht,
aber niemand konnte wirklich genau sagen, wie sicher dieser Kühlungsfaktor ist.
Wie sicher ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es jetzt sehr stark kühlt oder nur ein bisschen kühlt?
Und das hat sich in den letzten Jahren auch verändert schon bereits,
eben auch mit den Satellitenmissionen von unseren amerikanischen Kollegen,
aber die Unsicherheit ist immer noch sehr, sehr groß.
Und da kann eben Earthquake dazu beitragen.
Dass eben diese Unsicherheiten weiter reduziert werden.
Und wie ich auch schon vorhin gesagt hatte, es hängt sehr stark davon ab,
was für Wolken wir haben, was für Wolken wir auch in der Zukunft haben.
Und auch da kann EarthCare helfen. Wir können natürlich nicht 20 Jahre in die
Zukunft messen. Unser Satellit hat eine Lebensdauer von drei Jahren.
Das ist also relativ kurz. Wenn
man Klima betrachtet, sind drei Jahre im Prinzip ja ein Wimpernschlag.
Aber mit den Datensätzen als solches können wir unser Verständnis deutlich verbessern.
Und mit diesem verbesserten Verständnis können wir dann auch die Klimamodelle,
die uns dann die Zukunft voraussagen, in einer Art und Weise auch verbessern.
Es gibt ja sehr viele unterschiedliche Arten von Wolken. Also das kann man ja
rein optisch schon unterscheiden.
Und dann gibt es ja, was weiß ich, wie breit gefächert eigentlich so die Wolkentypisierung so ist.
Wie unterschiedliche Wolkenarten muss man so grob unterscheiden?
Also wir unterscheiden im Prinzip in drei unterschiedliche Schichten die Atmosphäre.
Das heißt, das ist die untere Schicht, das sind so die Atmosphären.
Die Wolken, die mehr oder weniger nah am Boden sind, Wolken in der mittleren
Atmosphäre, das kann dann so
zwischen zwei und acht Kilometer sein und die Wolken, die sehr hoch sind,
das sind dann zum Beispiel Zirnen, die man sieht oder auch, wenn man möchte,
auch die Kondensstreifen von Flugzeugen, das sind zum Beispiel Wolken,
die sehr weit oben sind und dann haben wir noch Gewitter, die praktisch durch
all diese drei Etagen durchgehen. Das ist, was wir so grob klassifizieren.
Und in diesen drei Etagen gibt es dann Wolken, die wir nennen es eher konvektiv,
also die so ein bisschen zusammengebauscht sind oder die stratiform sind,
die eben sehr flach sind und einen durchgängig grauen Tag zum Beispiel liefern.
Sprich, da gibt es ganz verschiedene Arten von Wolken.
Die Wolkenkataloge haben zig verschiedene Arten, Unterarten,
Unterklassifizierung.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele verschiedene Wolkentypen wir da haben,
aber so grundsätzlich unterscheiden wir in der Höhe, wo die Wolken sind und
wir unterscheiden in der Art und Weise, wie sie geformt werden. Das ist so grob die Idee.
Okay, also so wie man den Inuit nachsagt, dass sie 100 Worte für Schnee haben,
habt ihr ja auch 100 Worte für Wolken sozusagen.
Oh, mit Sicherheit mehr. Da bin ich auf jeden Fall sicher.
Und der Trick, den wir jetzt haben, oder die Fragestellung, die sich stellt,
ist, dass unter diesen 100 verschiedenen Wolken, sagen wir mal 100,
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen weniger, ich kann es jetzt wirklich
nicht genau sagen, jede dieser Wolken hat eine andere Art und Weise,
wie sie mit Strahlung interagiert.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du hohe, dünne Wolken hast, hoch wie in, sagen wir mal,
10 oder 12 Kilometer Höhe, dann führen die dazu, dass sich unser Klima erwärmt.
Also die hoch fliegen nicht.
Die hoch sind.
Nein, genau, die hochfliegen. Nehmen wir an, die sind vielleicht ein paar Kilometer
hoch, tief, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das sagt.
Die können von 8 bis 10 Kilometer Höhe gehen, sind dünn, also sprich so eine
Art Zirrus. Die führen zu einer Erwärmung unseres Klimas zum Beispiel.
Die tun weniger Licht zurückreflektieren, weniger Sonnenlicht reflektieren zurück ins All,
als wie sie von der Erde wieder zurückstreuen, sprich die Wärme,
die nach oben abgestrahlt wird, wird von denen eingefangen.
Wenn man dicke Wolken hat, auch in der Höhe, dann tun die mehr Sonnenlicht wegreflektieren,
als sie fangen. Das heißt, die führen zu einer Kühlung.
Und dasselbe ist auch, wenn wir weiter unten am Boden sind. Sehr dicke Wolken
am Boden sind auch sehr effektiv im Wegstreuen.
Und zum Beispiel Wassertröpfchen sind sehr viel besser im Wegstreuen von Sonnenstrahlung,
wie Eiswolken zum Beispiel.
Also es ist wirklich ein sehr komplexes Spiel zwischen der Wolken-Mikrophysik,
nennen wir das, welche Art von, sagen wir, Tröpfchen, Eispartikel wir haben
und der Strahlung, die dann eben entsprechend zurückgehalten wird oder zurückgestreut wird.
Gibt es denn eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jetzt im Rahmen dieser Mission
auch noch neue Wolkentypen entdeckt werden?
Weil ich meine, okay, man hat jetzt schon so diese Flugzeuge und man hat schon
den einen oder anderen Lieder mal reingehalten und denke im Wesentlichen hat
man so eine gewisse Vorstellung.
Aber jetzt kann man ja im Prinzip Wolken auch auf eine Art und Weise an Orten
beobachten, wo das vielleicht so bisher noch nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
war oder nicht so oft gemacht wurde. Pole, Ozeane, keine Ahnung.
Also ich glaube, da muss ich unsere Hoffnungen ein bisschen bremsen.
Ich denke, dass wir nicht unbedingt neue Wolken sehen werden,
aber was wir hoffen zu verbessern natürlich, ist, dass wir besser feststellen
können, welche Wolken wann wie häufig auch auftreten.
Das ist natürlich eine Sache, die wir haben seit den ersten Meteosat-Messungen,
irgendwann Ende der 80er Jahre, wissen wir, wo Wolken sind und die Messungen
der meteorologischen Systeme sind immer besser geworden.
Das heißt, wir wissen, wie viele Wolken da sind.
Wir wissen, wo die sind. Wir haben verschiedene Wolkentypen auch schon klassifiziert.
Aber was uns immer fehlt, ist die vertikale Struktur der Wolken.
Und das ist eigentlich viel entscheidender. Die kennen wir vom Boden aus.
Also sprich, ich wäre überrascht, wenn wir jetzt einen ganz neuen Wolkentyp
haben, ob wir dann einen, keine Ahnung, Cirrus Earthkerus oder sowas finden.
Ich glaube, das werden wir nicht haben.
Aber wir können das sehr viel besser charakterisieren. Wir können bessere Statistiken aufbauen.
Und das ist das, worum es uns eigentlich auch geht.
Hier bessere Statistiken, damit wir besser den Strahlungshaushalt der Erde kennenlernen.
Über die Wolken auch feststellen.
Genau, weil man stellt dann fest, von diesem Wolkentyp haben wir jetzt bei einem
Komplettdurchlauf so und so viel gesehen.
Was hast du gesagt, wie oft, wie lange dauert das, um einmal komplett rum zu sein?
25 Tage.
25 Tage, okay.
Ein bisschen weniger als einen Monat.
Okay, also so grob, man schaut halt mal so einen Monat auf die Erde,
das tut man dann über drei Jahre, dann kriegt man eine relativ gute Vorstellung davon,
was man jetzt wie oft wo findet Und dann kennt man ja dann sozusagen auch so,
okay, aber dieser Wolkentyp, der strahlt mehr ab oder der kühlt mehr und der
führt eher zur Erwärmung und was weiß ich, dann hat sich das über die drei Jahre
vielleicht auch noch leicht verändert, kann ja auch sein.
Was wir wahrscheinlich weniger sehen werden als die Veränderung von den Wolken
in dem Zeitraum, sind eher vielleicht auch singuläre Ereignisse.
Vulkanausbruch zum Beispiel. Wir hatten vorhin den Eyjafjallajökull,
den Vulkan in Island, aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Vulkane.
Hungartonga, da habe ich ja mögliche Schwierigkeiten, wie der wirklich heißt.
Was ich doch immer mit Vulkanen so ein Problem ist.
Die sind immer an Orten, wo die Sprachen...
Stimmt, da will immer keiner hin. Das sind nur irgendwelche Bergvölker, die sich dann was...
Wenn der Brock ausbrechen würde, wäre es einfach.
Das ist vollkommen klar.
Dass die eben in Regionen sind, die ein bisschen schwieriger aussehen.
Solche Sachen werden wir sehen. Die sind auch wichtig für uns.
Oder auch Industriegebiete.
Industriegebiete, Waldbrände, das ist ein anderer Punkt.
Auch hier.
Also solche Sachen werden wir sehen, wollen wir auch sehen. Eigentlich wollen
wir sie nicht sehen. Also abgesehen, wir wollen es eigentlich nicht sehen,
aber werden wir sie sehen.
Und auch hier haben wir dann aufgrund der neuartigen Messmethoden,
die wir haben, können wir auch hier mehr Wissen noch beisteuern,
was eben früher noch nicht da war. Das ist ein anderes Element dazu.
Eine andere Sache, die wir dann auch sehen können, wenn sie groß genug sind,
sind zum Beispiel Stürme, Extremwetterereignisse, Hurricanes,
Tornados und so weiter, wo man dann eben auch detaillierter sozusagen reinschauen kann.
Ja, sozusagen so richtig förmlich ins Auge des Geschehens, ins Auge des Flurms
reinschauen und da Erkenntnisse gewinnen.
Aber Graben, diese unterschiedlichen Wolken sind für uns eben extrem wichtig,
weil ich, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt hatte, unterschiedliche Wolken wirken
unterschiedlich auf die Strahlung und wirken unterschiedlich aufs Klima.
Und wir wissen, dass eben manche Wolkentypen weniger werden,
manche werden häufiger in einem verändernden Klima.
Und diesen ganzen Einfluss besser abzuschätzen, ist eben extrem wichtig,
damit wir wissen, wo wir stehen in Zukunft.
Wir reden immer davon, okay, wir müssen unsere Klimagase-Emissionen deutlich
reduzieren, das ist auch richtig, aber es sind noch so viele andere Elemente
im Klimasystem, die wir auch noch besser bestimmen müssen, die wir auch noch
besser verstehen müssen.
Drei Jahre Laufzeit ist ja eigentlich nicht so viel. Würde man sich ja mehr wünschen.
Das ist jetzt treibstoffbedingt? Bedingt?
Hauptsächlich treibstoffbedingt. Also bei anderen Satellitenmissionen ist ja
oft die Batterie, die sagen wir mal irgendwann schwächelt.
Aber bei uns dadurch, dass wir so niedrig fliegen und eben konstant dem Luftwiderstand
trotzen müssen, wir aber nur eine bestimmte Menge an Treibstoff mitnehmen können,
einfach aufgrund der Beschränkungen, die wir haben, ist die Lebensdauer von daher begrenzt.
Das hängt natürlich von der Sonnenaktivität ab.
Je höhere Sonnenaktivität, desto kürzer. Da haben sich die Verzögerungen,
die wir jetzt erfahren haben, wirken sich da positiv aus.
Wir sind ja jetzt dann wieder auf dem, sagen wir mal, wir haben das Maximum überschritten.
Und das könnte für eine Verlängerung der Lebenszeit.
Die Sonnenaktivität hat einen Einfluss auf die Laufzeit? Inwiefern?
Auf den Luftwiderstand, ja. Auf den Luftwiderstand und Strahlungsdruck.
Die Atmosphäre ist nicht statisch, sondern die Atmosphäre dehnt sich auch aus.
Und einer der Hauptelemente, die dazu führen, dass sich diese Atmosphäre auch
ausdehnen kann, ist zum Beispiel Sonnenaktivität.
Und wenn wir eine höhere Sonnenaktivität haben, dann muss ich mir vorstellen,
da kommt mehr Energie rein und das dehnt sich dann so ein bisschen aus.
Und an der oberen Kante der Atmosphäre ist diese Ausdehnung noch stärker.
Das heißt, es wird weniger dicht und man hat weniger Widerstand.
Es ist wie wenn man mehr Widerstand hat.
Es wird dichter. Die Dichte nimmt,
zu zur Erde hin und das heißt, wenn man sich das so vorstellen will,
eine dichtere Schicht kommt weiter hoch, geometrisch weiter weg und da fliegen
wir dann durch, unsere Höhe bleibt gleich, deswegen haben wir höheren Widerstand.
Die Atmosphäre drückt von innen nach außen, also sie wird dann nicht dünner,
sondern sie wird dann nicht dicker sozusagen.
Sie bläst sich auf, wie wenn man einen Luftballon warm macht,
dann dehnt er sich so ein bisschen aus.
Okay, und wir haben jetzt mehr oder weniger Sonnenaktivität erwartet?
Die drei Jahre ist für hohe Sonnenaktivität abgeschätzt und wir haben jetzt
aber eine niedrigere Sonnenaktivität, als für die diese Abschätzung gemacht wird.
Deswegen sind wir zuversichtlich im Moment, sagen wir mal, dass es die Möglichkeit
gibt, noch ein Jahr zu verlängern, wenn auch sonst.
Wie, das macht 30 Prozent aus?
Ungefähr, ja. Es hat eine deutliche Auswirkung.
Wenn man sich das aussuchen könnte, wann man denn die Missionen dann startet
oder so, würde man sie immer so starten, dass sie sozusagen das Maximum hinter
sich lassen und dann möglichst lange in dem Minimum fliegen.
Okay, also es könnte theoretisch sein, dass das Ding auch vier Jahre hält sozusagen.
Könnte auch sein, aber das hängt natürlich auch von anderen Faktoren ab und
auch wie es den Instrumenten geht. Ja, klar. Den aktiven Instrumenten hauptsächlich.
Also auf der wissenschaftlichen Seite wollen wir natürlich die Vision so lange
wie möglich haben, das ist vollkommen klar.
Und wir sehen natürlich auch, dass bei vielen Visionen die Lebensdauer sehr
viel länger war, als wie sie ursprünglich angenommen wurde.
Ja, Voyager 1 funkt immer noch.
Voyager 1 funkt immer noch und ein Grund, weshalb Voyager 1 immer noch funkt,
ist, dass er keine Atmosphäre hat.
Ja, das ist ein großer Vorteil.
Und das ist eben bei uns die Problematik. Viele meiner Kollegen sagen,
ja, wir bauen unsere Systeme immer nur für ein paar Jahre, aber dann halten die viel, viel länger.
Aber hier im speziellen Fall von EarthCare mit aktiven Instrumenten,
das macht auch noch einen großen Unterschied, ob wir ein aktives Instrument
haben oder ein passives Instrument haben und eben aufgrund der Tatsache,
dass wir so niedrig fliegen, ist die Hoffnung,
dass wir anstatt drei 20 Jahre machen, ist null.
Die Hoffnung, dass wir vielleicht anstatt drei vielleicht vier machen,
hier schaue ich in Björns blaue Augen, die ist natürlich immer gegeben und wir
hoffen, dass wir auch da hinkommen von der wissenschaftlichen Seite her.
Ja klar, das kann ich mir natürlich vorstellen. Ein Jahr mehr macht ja nochmal richtig viel aus.
Und trotzdem wird man ja dann, selbst wenn er nicht mehr fliegt,
von den Daten wahrscheinlich noch sehr lange zehren können.
Und oft ist es ja nun auch so, die Instrumente sind ja dann in der Regel immer
Prototypen, sprich gab es halt so noch nie, hat man noch nie so gebaut und ist ja dann immer wieder,
also technologisch an sich gab es
das schon mal, aber dann halt in dieser konkreten Form und Nutzung nicht.
Ist denn das sozusagen auch Instrumentarium, was man dann in Zukunft vielleicht
auf normalen Wettersatelliten sehen könnte oder ist das jetzt zu abgefahren?
Also ich denke, die Eolos-Mission ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür.
Da gibt es jetzt eine Nachfolgemission, wo das experimentelle Instrument,
der LIDA, der eben Wind messen konnte,
nochmal in verbesserter Form gebaut wird, weil man erstens nachgewiesen hat,
okay, da gibt es einen operationellen Nutzen, das lohnt sich wirklich,
das ganze Geld und den Aufwand zu investieren.
Und das könnte bei uns auch der Fall sein, aber das steht in den Sternen, wir hoffen es.
Für uns ist das Wichtigste jetzt erstmal, dass der Start klappt und funktioniert
und dass wir zeigen können, es war es wert.
Der ganze Aufwand und die ganzen Anstrengungen, die da über Jahrzehnte gemacht
worden sind und dass wir gute Ergebnisse haben.
Es ist natürlich so, dass selbst die Mission, wie du auch gerade gesagt hast,
auch wenn sie nach drei Jahren zu Ende ist, wir hoffen natürlich,
dass wir so tolle und gute Daten haben, dass die Wissenschaftler noch über Jahre,
Jahrzehnte daran arbeiten können. Das ist die eine Seite.
Das heißt, häufig sagen die Leute, deine Mission ist zu Ende gegangen.
Ich habe auf Aeolus gearbeitet. Die sagen, deine Mission ist zu Ende.
Nein, nein, das ist nur das Ende des Satelliten.
Die Mission geht weiter. Die Mission lautet, wir wollen mit den Daten von dem
Satelliten eben auch weiter Wissenschaft betreiben, auch weiter Erkenntnisse
schaffen. Das ist das Ziel.
Auf der anderen Seite arbeiten wir natürlich auch mit internationalen Kooperationen zusammen.
Das heißt, das ist für uns auch wichtig, wie wir vorhin auch schon erwähnt hatten,
die amerikanischen Kollegen hatten schon Satelliten, die was Ähnliches gemessen haben wie wir.
Wir haben momentan einen chinesischen Satelliten, der auch etwas Ähnliches misst
wie wir. Nicht dasselbe, das ist alles ein bisschen anders.
Und unsere amerikanischen Kollegen planen eine Satellitenmission in den 30er
Jahren, in den 2030er Jahren, die auch wieder ähnliche Sachen misst wie wir.
Wir glauben immer noch, dass wir vermutlich einen Referenzdatensatz erstellen würden.
Referenz in dem Sinn, dass insbesondere zum Beispiel das ATLIT,
dieses Slidergerät, Da sind wir momentan kein Nachfolger und wie wir auch vorhin
schon erwähnt haben, das Bauen von so einem Satelliten dauert einigermaßen lange.
Aber es gibt Nachfolgeprojekte, wo wir dann eine lange Zeitreihe auch aufbauen können.
Das beginnt mit den amerikanischen Missionen 2007, glaube ich,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere, die angefangen haben, diese Vertikalprofile von
Aerosolen und auch von Wolken zu messen.
Die haben das zum Teil bis letztes Jahr gemacht. Das waren wirklich Satelliten,
die, weil sie auch sehr hoch geflogen sind, sehr lange gelebt haben.
Jetzt kommen wir rein mit EarthCare. Wir hatten Iolos dazwischen drin.
Das war zwar ein Windlider, aber auch das hat Aerosole und auch Wolkeninformationen geliefert.
Wir haben die chinesische Mission, die nennt sich ACDL, die im Moment fliegt.
Wir werden dann in Zukunft die amerikanische Mission haben und dann vielleicht
wieder eine europäische oder eine japanische oder eine ähnliche Mission.
Das heißt, wir bauen unsere Zeitreihen immer aufeinander auf.
Es ist klar, die sind immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich in der Frequenz,
in der Höhe, in was sie genau vermessen.
Das ist immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich, aber da springt dann die Genialität
unserer Wissenschaftler rein, die eben aus all diesen unterschiedlichen Daten setzen,
dann trotzdem, wenn wir auf die geophysikalischen Produkte zurückgehen,
wie zum Beispiel Wolkenhöhe, dann können die das trotzdem alles miteinander zusammenbauen.
Und unsere 3-Jahres-Mission EarthCare, die vielleicht nur drei Jahre macht,
kann dann trotzdem helfen, um diese gesamte Datenreihe von Anfang der 2000er,
2030 oder länger auch besser zu charakterisieren.
Wir sind praktisch auch hier wieder ein Element in der internationalen,
in der globalen Zusammenarbeit.
Ja, jetzt muss nur noch fliegen. So, ich weiß nicht, ist das jetzt für euch
beide eigentlich die erste Mission, die ihr in dem Sinne so begleitet oder habt
ihr schon mal diesen ganzen Startfrust?
Ich glaube, wir haben beide schon etliche,
Momente erlebt, aber es ist trotzdem immer wieder was Besonderes,
weil so ein Start ist natürlich sagen wir mal so ein bisschen binäres Ereignis.
Ich meine, genau, entweder es klappt oder nicht und wenn es nicht klappt,
dann kann es nicht nur ein bisschen nicht klappen, sondern es ist halt dann
leider fatal. Hat es schon mal nicht geklappt?
Nee, ich hatte Glück bisher. Ich weiß noch, bei Greys Mission war ich dabei
und da kommt die Rakete aus so einer Röhre raus und da dachte ich jetzt explodiert
alles, aber es war dann doch so geplant. Aber ich hatte Glück bisher.
Ich nicht. Meine erste Vision bei der ESA, da war ich zwar nicht direkt daran
beteiligt, aber es war die erste Erdbeobachtungsvision, die gelauncht wurde. Das war Cryosat.
Das war 2006, glaube ich. Und seitdem bin ich ein bisschen launchgeschädigt.
Glaube ich.
Das war schon ziemlich dramatisch einschneidend. Umgekehrt.
Also Cryosat 1, es gab dann noch einen zweiten, der funktioniert hat.
Und da muss ich sagen, das war eine großartige Sache, was die ESA damals geschafft
hat, dass wir wirklich die Mission verloren haben, dann gleich wieder,
die nächste, praktisch noch in derselben Nacht definiert haben. Das war wirklich toll.
Aber ich bin seitdem ein wenig Launch geschädigt, wann immer es Launches gibt.
Und das müssen nicht mal die sein, die Mission, an der ich beteiligt war.
Ich war an Earthcare beteiligt, ich war an Sentinel-5 Precursor beteiligt.
Und jedes Mal, wenn die Launches waren, werde ich extrem nervös.
Und ich bin eigentlich ansonsten nicht jemand, der so leicht aus der Fassung zu bringen ist.
Aber da merke ich, wie der Hals trocken wird, wie ich dann anfange aufzustehen, rumzulaufen.
Also ich sehe mich da schon Ende März hier in ESOC die letzten zehn Minuten
irgendwo mich verkriechen oder irgendwas.
Also es ist schon immer ein sehr spannendes und einschneidendes Erlebnis.
Also ihr werdet hier vor Ort sein, weil die Übernahme natürlich das eigentliche Ereignis ist.
Klar, der Start muss funktionieren, aber dann die Übernahme und die Inbetriebnahme,
da geht ja dann die Arbeit eigentlich auch erst so richtig los, oder?
Also wenn man dann eben das erste Signal sieht von dem Satelliten,
das ist dann Das ist ein super Moment, das ist natürlich genial.
Und dann geht, Gott sei Dank, für uns die Arbeit erst richtig los.
Das ist genau das, worauf wir uns freuen.
Es kommen die ersten Produkte, dann kommen die ersten Produkte von dem einen
Instrument, dann kommen die von dem anderen Instrument, dann kommen die gemeinsam.
Also es gibt eine ganze Menge an ganz fantastischen und ganz tollen Ereignissen,
die sich jetzt in den nächsten Jahren so aneinanderreihen werden.
Das Ende dann, wie gesagt, nicht mit dem Ende der Satellitenmission,
Dann kommen dann wissenschaftliche Publikationen, Konferenzen.
Es geht immer weiter. Also es ist für uns eigentlich jetzt der Startschuss.
Für viele unserer Kollegen natürlich, die den Satelliten seit 20 Jahren bauen,
für die ist es dann das Ende in gewisser Hinsicht. Aber für uns geht die Sache
erst so richtig los, nicht?
Ja, dann ist Schluss mit den Trockenübungen, wie jetzt hier bei Raumzeit.
Ich sage vielen, vielen Dank für die ausführlichen Ausführungen zur Mission
und Wissenschaft und was sonst alles noch interessant ist rund um EarthCare.
Ja, habt ihr noch irgendwas,
hinzuzufügen?
Nein, nur vielen Dank.
Wir freuen uns auf EarthCare und danke, dass wir dabei sein durften.
Für jeden, der Interesse hat, das zu verfolgen, einfach auf esa.int gehen,
EarthCare oder einfach einfach so EarthCare googeln.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert heutzutage auch schon sehr gut und wir sind dann
auch bei dem Launch Ende Mai, bei dem Start der Mission, gibt es auch einen
Livestream, so ein bisschen Werbung machen, wo man auch zuschauen kann.
Unser Launch ist spät, der ist 20 nach 12 Mitternacht, also für all die Leute,
die ein bisschen länger wach bleiben wollen, ist das durchaus eine Möglichkeit
auch den Launch direkt zu sehen.
Wie pünktlich muss das Ding sein?
Wir haben keine,
interstellare Mission, wo man ein gewisses Zeitfenster hat.
Das ist egal, oder?
Im Prinzip ist es egal, das bestimmt SpaceX.
Verstehe, alles klar. Na gut, dann muss man halt vielleicht ein bisschen früher
oder später aufstehen, je nachdem. Alright, gut.
Danke dir.
Das war's, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's bei RONZEIT, bald geht's wieder
weiter. Ich sag tschüss, bis bald.